Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello, hi, hi, hi, howdy, howdy, howdy.
Welcome in, welcome in, welcome, welcome, welcome!
Hello!
How's it going?
Right before this, I was, I was, I was going through my
closets in the maid cafe.
Going through my stuff.
I'm getting ready for packing for my move.
So I'm like,
Darth Binky.
Hi, Mito.
Hello!
We eating good today.
Are we?
We got Alan Wake going on.
We're with this guy one more time before we go into Alan
Wake 2, maybe.
The move is happening.
Well, it's fine.
It's actually kind of fun because I'm like a, you know, I'm
a bit of a collector.
And so I'm like going through some things and I'll find
something and be like, Yeah, this was a cool thing that I
got.
That just got shoved into my closet.
So that's fun.
It's always fun.
But everything is dusty and hopefully I don't sneeze.
Reintroducing yourself to your treasures.
Yes.
Baby Cori, thank you so much for the fun.
Get the thank you.
But I'm also having to do the dreaded task of like...
you know, when you like something, but you're like, I must,
I must really love this thing to take it with me, you know,
where you're like, I like this thing, I don't want to part
with it, but at the same time, yeah, Marie Kondo is judging
me.
Keep or donate.
That is, that is the sad truth.
But I have, one thing, a lot of stuff that I've been
donating is Sanrio things.
of like cinnamarol stuff.
Crayon name.
Thank you so much for the fun.
Thank you.
And luckily, I don't feel so bad donating that because I'm
like, I know that cinnamarol and Sanrio and stuff like that
is pretty popular.
So I feel that like someone's gonna go to the thrift store
and be like, what is this treasure trove?
It's my birthday today and we don't stream is the perfect
and...
Bionic Ebo!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Thank you so much for the Hakka Supa!
No!
You guys make me feel so bad when you send Hakka Supas on
your birthday!
You should be getting yourself something so nice!
I will accept cinnamural donations.
Yeah.
Somewhere in the virtual world, the thrift store is
overflowing with Sanrio merchandise.
So, yeah.
I hope that they go to a good home.
Look, I'm keeping the ones that are like my favorite, super
ultra favorite things.
And then everything else, I'm like, okay, I can part with
you.
uh uh uh i'm hesitant of it but i am i am doing it don't let
iron mouse know where you donate to i think probably she has
a lot of the stuff i have too probably oh hiyo gozaiimasu oh
hiyo gozaiimasu oh hiyo these are a few of our favorite
things I've been looking into moving services and all of the
fun things, all the fancy things I must look into.
So, yeah, busy, busy, but I can't wait.
Remember all those Metal Gear acrylic standees I got?
All those teeny tiny ones of every single character.
I can't wait to take all of them apart.
I can't wait.
I just put them all together.
I can't wait to take them apart.
Hello, Minto, and I booze like you.
Excited for a chill?
Question mark?
Should be chill, right?
It's a day stream with Minto after doing some home
maintenance.
Drained my water heater for the first time and learned some
more new things about taking care of a home.
Look at you!
Como!
Oh my gosh, you're like doing it.
You're doing the thing.
You're doing the thing that everybody hates to do.
Look at you, go!
Good job.
Every single character, meanwhile, is 99 figures of Ocelot.
Nagi-san, happy birthday!
I'm not doing anything.
You know what?
That's a good thing to do.
That's a good thing to do, too.
It's just take it easy and not do anything, you know?
Yes, yes.
Responsibilities.
Don't think about responsibilities today.
Think about only your birthday!
Am I moving to a new time zone?
Hmm, yes.
But I still plan on streaming my normal times.
I think probably times like these this time might be a
little more difficult to do for me.
Like, you know, right now it's 4 p.m.
EST for me.
But we will cross that road when we come to it.
I will figure out.
No, no, no rip EU.
No rip EU.
It might just end up being a little bit different.
But it's my first, like, big, big move.
You know, I died and I was in one maid cafe, and then I
haunted another maid cafe, and now I'm gonna go hunt a far
away cafe.
So, So, are you going to move in with us?
Is that an invitation or?
I leave for the Appalachian...
The Appalachian Trail on Wednesday.
The whole thing is about 2,200 miles.
And I want to hike it all.
Seeing my Oshi go to the ends of the earth just to give us
another smile is so inspired.
You were so inspired.
You decided to hike thousands of miles.
Good luck, Phoenix.
moving is such a nightmare for me i moved over a year and a
half ago and still unpacking stuff really i don't i don't
it's 5 a.m for chinese fan i'm sorry thank you for waking up
i'm sorry um i uh what was i saying um oh i don't have so
it's funny like i have a ton of stuff but it's all right so
I don't think as long as I have like a display cabinet I
can't imagine it would take me so long to unpack stuff you
know that's the hope at least give getting my figures out
getting my display stuff out thank you for la-la
just don't overwork yourself too much Yeah, no worries.
I think it will still be not so difficult for me.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
But we're back with Alan Wake.
We beat the game, actually.
But today we are doing...
Extras.
Wait.
Wait, where are...
Oh, special!
Special one and special two.
I was like, um.
Hi, Mint.
I've been watching videos and came to your stream to write
an injustice.
An injustice.
Can I have this adorable ghost's hand in marriage?
Is there another ghost haunting you?
Or?
Oh, spirits.
That's not me.
Oh, spirit.
Other place...
Give us a sign!
Namiye!
Thank you so much for the...
Right!
Thank you!
Hello, hello, hello!
Welcome everybody!
Welcome, welcome!
I hope I said your name right.
Nami?
Namiye?
Thank you!
Torgo, thank you!
Way back, thank you!
gifted i'm about to go fight the darkness right now aka my
night shift job if i ain't gonna miss mint playing alan wake
good luck with work alan dodge the question alan dodge a
masterful marriage parry again boss i don't know what you're
talking about
hello biggie looking forward to your show friday thank you
No, Kanye, boy, why are you irresponsible now?
It's been a good minute.
I've returned.
I hope you've been doing well and that your health is not
faltered despite my lack of healthcare installments.
Forgive my name.
Much has happened in my absence.
I'm curious what is going on.
Hope everyone has been doing great.
Thank you for the hug, I'm so proud.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Fox Eye!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Phil, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Brandon, hello!
I'm doing great.
I hope you are too.
Shall we get into it then?
Shall we get into...
Oh wait.
Kanye irresponsible spending yeast.
What happened to...
Don't spend it irresponsibly, everybody.
Alan, start!
I like how Alan has become our little Pokemon.
We command him.
We're like, Alan jump.
Alan run.
Alan dodge.
Alan start.
He's doing everything but Alan waking.
Alan spend.
No, no, no.
This isn't much.
Oh my gosh, please don't say that.
No, it's more than enough.
Thank you, Henry.
Thank you for streaming.
It's an awesome post of B-Day present.
Happy birthday, Henry.
Happy birthday.
Yes.
I choose Alan.
Alan, I choose you.
Do we though?
Do we choose Alan?
We're still working on Alan climb.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, Darko!
I saw, I saw, I haven't gotten it yet, but I saw what you
sent to the PO box.
Thank you.
I got sent pictures.
People are sending things to PO box.
Thank you very much.
Was it a labubu?
No, Ho Ho sent a mint labubu.
Yeah, Ho Ho sent one.
Sure thing.
Thank you!
A mint bubu.
Labenki?
Labenki.
I didn't, it wasn't, it's not an actual Laboobu, but it's
like, I think it's a Laboobu skin, and then the face is me.
Like, like it, maybe, I don't know.
I don't know how she did it.
Sasuka's strongest eyeball.
I love her.
I don't think they have skins.
I don't know if it was skinned or not.
Hmm.
I'll have to see once I get it.
I received photos of things from the PO box from Manesan
this morning.
But yeah.
Special one is the signal and special two is the rider.
That's Alan Wake.
He's the rider.
I am so curious.
Existing checkpoint will be overwritten.
Yeah, that's fine.
Right?
I'm so curious though what these special episodes are going
to be about because I'm like...
Previously on Alan Wake.
Oh, I guess we'll...
I only know is the dark presence, held my wife captive, and
used her to make me write a horror story that came true.
I guess this is a good summary, right?
I believe me had been aware enough to write my escape into
the story.
And then he hugged her.
And she cringed to death.
Helen?
I saved Alice.
Then wrote a better ending for the story.
But not without a price.
I was trapped somewhere in the dark place.
A strange zone somewhere beyond our world.
Yeah, yeah.
It's an ocean.
Special feature one.
Oh, thank you!
After the completion of any difficult undertaking, there are
mixed emotions.
Accomplishment and relief.
Sadness, depression.
For a while, everything is about to work.
Like an illness, it consumed you.
Changed you.
You locked yourself away from the world to do it, and now
you need to recover.
Learn to live without it.
Find a way to crack open the door and let the light back in.
She's just going around town.
I knew this place It was familiar But wrong somehow How is
it wrong?
It looks the same to me
Welcome to the Welcome to the Everything had a surreal
Dreamlike quality Welcome to the I had a disturbing feeling
of Yeah, I was gonna say this is the beginning of the I have
no idea why I was here or where I had been but something was
waiting for me at the back of the diner uh-oh try the coffee
just don't blame me when you fall in love because it'll
break your heart when you have to leave uh-oh they're
transparent here is no longer human nothing but black coffee
under a thin layer of skin she's disappearing wait can i see
into her brain wait is that what am i literally seeing her
brain there i can't believe you see that i'm having a
conversation with me what is going on there what is that are
you on your own or is your way oh wait i think that's her
hair bun wait i think it's her hair bun it's so funny
everybody are ghosts i could really use a tune
the deer fish also do you see outside it's all smoky and
stuff there's like oh look at it what is happening
oh my god i was gonna read the donos once everybody shut up
in the in this game but everybody's just yapping jacks thank
you so much for the oka donald happy birthday how did you
forget it's your birthday happy birthday
hello nico picas thank you so much also for the donald
today's not my birthday that was yesterday oh happy belated
birthday i'm so sorry I couldn't watch live, sadly, because
of work and exam stress.
Just wanted to tell you that listening to you, Yapp soothes
the little aches.
The daily cry leaves on my soul.
I'm happy.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, guys.
I don't know why all the don'tos today, but thank you so
much.
I really appreciate it.
All right.
I thought he was wearing a t-shirt, like a...
T-shirt.
Alright.
We're walking to the restroom.
We've done all of this before.
I've played this game before!
Don't go in there, young man.
You can hurt yourself in the dark.
I don't like the clock tick.
Do you guys hear that?
Here's the bathroom.
Oh.
Push.
Whoa!
Wait!
We're actually able to go in!
is there a light a light Alan P oh Alan Alan listen Alan
listen no deeper what focus you're losing yourself I will
try to help the best I can but it's up to you find a better
point of contact what do you mean I cannot hear you please
you're the one making all this happen concentrate This is
what's happening.
Oh.
Too deep.
Can't take the pressure.
It's too much.
Oh my god, Alan, you need to wake.
Wake found himself face to face with himself.
At the sight of myself, the dream suddenly became lucid.
The dark place.
Remember who you...
Oh, yes I do.
Oh, oh.
It's not the light itself.
But what it represents.
Oh,
and a gun, you'll need a gun.
This is not a gun.
Oh, it's not a gun.
Just kidding.
Be careful.
I will try to find a better point of contact.
I didn't understand Zane's message.
And knowing where I was didn't fix anything.
Something had gone wrong after I had finished departure.
Miro was here.
Who the heck is...
Oh, is that one of the brothers?
Miro is not here.
Oh, are they all going to be wanting to attack me once
I'm...
Oh, once I leave.
I'm scared.
Ehhhh!
What the hell was that?
Oh, it's a rambly.
Oh, gosh.
Oh!
The diner could become deserted.
Then the door was smashed.
off his hinges and wake had to fight for his life oh no i
don't like wait don't tell me that oh i don't like that at
all what do you mean the door was smashed off his hinges and
i have to fight for my life wait what alan you control the
story just say don't do it say no say no say that sounds
like a terrible idea
Oh, oh my god!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, there's so many guys here.
Oh shoot, how do I dodge again?
Oh shoot!
Ouch!
Can I leave?
Kick!
Okay.
Oh, wait.
The world has become twisted.
Whoa.
These trees didn't belong here.
Where do they belong?
Okay.
Whoa!
Is there something over here?
I'm just checking.
Oh, it's like a phone.
Oh, no trees!
Alan had to fight for his life.
Alan made it.
Wait, um, hold on.
I remember remembering how to...
Shoot.
No.
Remembering how to play this game?
Ah!
Ouch!
Oh my god.
Helen ambush!
Alan run!
Alan reload.
Look, doesn't it look bright enough here that the darkness
wouldn't attack me here?
Oh my god!
Sorry!
Oh my god, they scare me so bad!
They scare me so bad, you guys!
Run, Alan run!
Oh, am I not safe in here?
Oh, shoot.
I don't think I am.
Wait, why is it so bright then?
Sorry, guys.
Merely the concept of light.
Must be.
Oh, the door shut.
That's nice.
Oh, I can't go upstairs.
Okay.
Alan's scared.
Alan spooked.
Oh, look.
We're like going through everything at the moment.
Oh no, that's not a manuscript page, is it?
Why is the...
Why is it blue?
Da-ba-di, da-ba-di.
I knew it was my writing, but the words were jumbled,
dream-like fragments.
Oh, so you're writing.
The rounds of slippery stones throw away from the tent.
Me no breathe!
She was startled by the fog.
I was startled by the phone.
Who was phone?
What?
Oh my god, it's phone.
The GPS system was working.
I hadn't expected that.
Don't breathe.
I'm breathing!
Hello?
I'm trying to reach you.
Can you hear me?
Can you hear me now?
Yeah?
Yes.
Listen, I can help you.
but you're drifting deeper.
I can't reach you.
You must come to me.
Okay.
I can't make
you...
Follow the signal.
It made no sense for the GPS system to work.
I doubted any satellite was in range here.
These were alien skies, but it was God-like towards
something.
Towards Zane?
My flashlight wasn't working.
I don't know why.
Ouch, ouch.
We got a new flashlight.
Heavy duty?
Follow the words.
Oh, flare gun?
I'll take that, yeah.
What if there's one that says, like, evil guy?
Recharge.
Don't get too close.
Ooh.
Nice.
Okay.
Is this door open now?
Do I go...
I guess I go back outside the way I can.
Oh, wait.
Is this a door?
Whoa!
The dark place was playing tricks on me.
It wouldn't stay still.
Oh, fun.
We're like going through everywhere that we've been.
Oh.
The town itself turned against Wake.
Oh, no.
No.
Crack bone!
What the hell was that?
Bringing a new meaning to words have power.
This is literally Alan Wake.
It was exactly that.
It was exactly the emojis you guys are using.
Oh, man.
Maybe I should use my flare gun on the big...
What's it called?
Whatever's going to be the cars.
What is it going to attack me?
Follow the GPS signal.
Oh, I guess I go towards the yellow.
Okay.
As usual.
As you did in the regular game too.
Oh, that's a lot though.
That's a lot.
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Ouch, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, shoot.
I do think I need to run.
Oh my gosh.
I'm going to go back to my regular.
do i go in here okay stop running in slow motion please i
know this is a dream but like out the door hurts everything
hurt out the door hurts tools out the tool i died sticks and
stones may break my bones but tools i thought the world
Words were not supposed to hurt me!
No way.
It oozed hate.
Run, run, run!
Dodge, dodge, dodge!
Okay, what if I, like, get it from here?
I think I'm pretty protected over here.
Oh my god, don't get hit by the tools.
Come on now.
Be careful.
I picked up a flare.
And some stuff.
And a shotgun.
And...
I'm guessing I have...
Oh, I just keep following the signal light.
Wait, what else is in here?
I think they're not doing so hot out there.
I think they're pretty angry at me even.
I wonder if I can get it from the door.
Anything in
here.
Wait, how do I use my flare?
There we go.
I'm guessing this door doesn't work.
So I do have to...
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Dodge, dodge, please!
This is a tough area to be locked in, too.
Oh my god.
I'm stuck.
Good.
Oh, jeez!
I didn't know the DLC was going to be like extra nightmare
mode.
What the hell?
Where's that kill?
Would you speak up to me?
They're like, you better get good at the game.
Stupid.
Is there anything else in here that I can pick up?
Or do I have to spawn in everything?
Did you pick hard difficulty?
No!
I picked... Maybe I should have picked easy!
Everything I saw was familiar and yet it wasn't.
Wow.
Hello?
I cannot keep up.
You're going too deep.
I will try to guide you.
Follow the signal.
I'm trying!
You must face yourself.
Follow me?
I'm facing myself?
Oh.
Oh!
what's going on oh the gps system was supposed to lead me to
zane it's going crazy how are fearing with it i had to keep
trying i wouldn't survive alone uh-huh okay
i'm looking for any supplies oh game is hard guys game is
hard
still go this way.
Jump.
Whoa.
DLC is only for true wakeheads.
I'll do my best.
Flash!
Flare!
Tools!
I have to use words to give supplies!
Aw, man.
Give me tools!
Okay, don't drop please.
Oh my gosh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
You guys saw that the ammo fell!
The ammo fell!
Flash!
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Washbang.
Don't get too close.
It bites.
That's me.
Oh.
Oh, that's...
Sarah Breaker.
Sarah Breaker, Bright Falls Finest.
The red hot cop chick with the lightning fast broomstick.
I don't remember this episode of...
of Sesame Street.
Why is this, oh, because of the words.
Her debut book, the only girl in the book house delves deep
into the double life of having a successful law enforcement
career while being involved in a secret society.
How does daddy's little trooper fit into an old fashioned
fraternity?
What?
What does that mean?
Let's get my flares out.
Um...
Reload...
Okay.
Follow the signal.
Oh, geez.
Use your arms, Alan.
I remember this park.
I used to have a statue there.
Oh, I think there's a guy there?
Oh, I think there's many guys here.
Okay.
Oh, geez.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
And birds!
Oh my god.
Oh shoot!
Oh my god, I'm trying to shoot!
Guys, this is hard.
What the hell?
This is so hard!
Oh my god!
Please!
Give me a second!
Ah!
Okay.
You.
Are there still birds?
Oh, my God.
I'm getting...
I'm getting my booty beat here.
This is crazy.
Nice recovery.
I was trying to, like, see if I could gather them all into
the same place to use the flare gun.
Maybe I should have a flash.
bang for next time, maybe.
Golly.
More tools, please!
Oh.
Is this American nightmare?
No, this is my nightmare.
Okay, well, I guess we don't have to go searching for stuff.
Like, if there is...
If there's tools, or if there's ammo or something, we know
where to get it.
Kind of situation.
because we'll see tools.
Oh, is this not a checkpoint?
What was that?
Oh, all the lights are turning on.
Oh, oh, nice.
Yeah?
Where are you?
Look, I'm trying to follow your goddamn signal.
The dark place is playing tricks on you.
What is this?
I can help you if you just stop sinking.
I'm not trying.
This is bullshit.
It's happening again.
Brace yourself.
Oh, no.
What do you mean, brace myself?
Oh, good.
Oh, wait, I think this is a visual glitch.
You're in their territory now, Minto.
And he was telling me I was going too deep.
It was ridiculous.
But I was more scared than amused.
I felt like I was being hindered by an unseen force in ways
I couldn't fight.
All I could do was keep going.
But I'm going in deeper.
Good.
this way this way
oh shoot out out out out out oh my god please please please
please these guys are ruthless holy moly holy Holy moly!
They just...
Oh my gosh!
I was trying to use my...
Okay.
Oh!
Yeah.
Try and get me.
Asshole.
Yeah.
Oucha!
Stop it!
Oh my god.
There's too many of these guys.
Oh my god!
They are just keep throwing shit at me!
Oh my god, I'm so dead.
I'm so dead.
Wait, my flash...
It's time.
I don't care.
Oh my god, he's not even dead.
I am getting bullied!
Oh my god!
Gosh!
Um, signal goes this way.
i'm getting bullied hardcore oh not this oh memory all alone
in the moonlight i can smile at the old day oh i don't see
barry oh yes wait maybe that's him that's the way to the
chopper the chopper this happened before we found barry
they're gone investigate the flare boy i see more things.
Oh, recharge.
Get to the chopper!
Anything else?
It's so dark, I can't see anything.
Classic Alan Wake.
Okay.
I'll have my flare gun ready.
For now.
Oh.
I am...
This is high-key stressing me out.
Oh,
okay.
It does look stressful.
Luckily, it's like...
You know what?
Screw it.
Oh.
I can't see anything.
I'm lost.
Just run.
Run to where?
I don't know.
Oh my gosh.
Hide behind the tree.
Alan hide.
Alan dodge.
Alan.
Oh, it's here.
Oh, shoot.
We have nowhere to hide for right here.
Alan go.
And defense.
I guess we go back through the church.
They're being...
They're being obnoxious and they're in there over there.
They're being They're doing their own thing in there
Oh, of course I do Alan, it's your memory just conjured you
said it was a lucid Oh, no, the deer
This is not gonna be good Okay Oh my god!
Where's the key?
Maybe if I'm like here, I can just like kind of...
It can't get me in here.
It can't get me behind here, right?
There's no way.
We might be able to juke this.
We might be able to juke this a little bit.
Oh, the key!
I see it!
Oh yeah.
Yeah, stupid!
I'm chilling!
Where is it?
It's like...
Sometimes I feel it, because, like, my controller will
rumble.
Oh, there it is.
I can get it.
Come on!
Oh!
Oh, holy cow!
That was so close!
Okay, there's just one more.
Just the deer's bottom half.
We can get it!
Nice camping zone.
Nice.
Key.
Now you're thinking with the world...
Oh, that's...
Oh!
I got the door open.
Run for it.
I'm running for it.
Four tools, please.
Okay.
Oh, flare?
Oh, more ammo?
Oh, I'm... Oh, okay.
Wow, amazing.
Okay.
Alright!
Holy cow!
Oh!
Okay.
14 months, thank you!
I wish Alan would just listen to Zane.
Twisting.
It was too big on the inside.
He couldn't see the ceiling.
Something was moving in there.
He was lost.
He couldn't find the exit.
Asshole!
Kick.
Alan, kick!
Oh.
Good.
Uh-oh.
Are they behind me?
Are they down here?
Oh, geez.
Okay, checkpoint.
Okay, I have my flares.
I'm like, okay, I only have flares.
Gah.
The shifts were getting more severe.
I wasn't sure if the place got bigger or I got smaller.
The signal was going haywire.
Blast.
I would have to find my way out of here on my own.
I think that's it.
I think I wasted it.
Oh,
there's so many of them.
What the heck?
I have to like be careful.
Alan regret.
Just a little bit.
What's that sound?
I have to be careful not to use it.
Like I have to accidentally shine my flashlight on it.
Oh,
I think it's the sound of the furnace.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Of course it is.
Oh, nice.
Okay, okay.
Oh, there is no signal down here.
I just realized.
Wait, is this going to be like a maze?
No.
Oh, my God.
I'm teeny tiny.
I'm just a little mouse.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, there's...
I don't even know where...
Oh, my God.
Stop coming at me.
Okay.
The shifts were getting more severe.
Yeah, the game is getting more severe.
Where I got smaller.
The signal was going haywire.
I would have to find my way out of here on my own.
Oh, my God.
Turn it around all dramatically.
Like, huh?
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, the difficulty spike is kind of crazy.
I don't know if I'm cut out for this, you guys.
I'm Alan weak.
I don't know if I cut out for this.
Okay, I'll just have to assume as I get to these guys, just
flare it up, baby.
Flare it up.
Oh, oh, I'm accidentally hitting things.
Ouch, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Flare.
I feel like I'm wasting my flares, though.
This guy, this guy is a big guy.
Oh, you're still here?
It's nice that they activate so easily, but I feel like I
also have to not waste them.
Alright, I'm letting my Oh, I hear him.
Oh, no!
Dang it!
See you like that!
I hear more of him.
Oh, shoot!
He got his butt.
I think I hear more.
Alan weak?
No, you're mean to strength!
Ah!
Dang it!
I tried to run out of the way.
I can't believe he didn't get hit by a single...
One of those, though.
I cannot believe.
She didn't get hit by a single one.
I think I just have to keep going.
I think I just have to keep running.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Blast.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
I see it.
Alan, climb!
Climb!
We made it!
Maybe, I hope.
Okay, we made it.
Helen, climb!
Zane left me a page.
He was trying to help me.
He did?
Oh.
Whoa.
Scream?
Tremor?
Wall?
What's the wall for?
Cool.
Oh.
Uh...
Friend!
Ah, nice!
Alan Friend!
Barry!
Yauza!
Hey, bestseller!
Looking good!
Barry!
Well, no shit, what gave me away?
For the see-through thing?
I'm a figment of your imagination.
Just like pretty much everything else you see here.
Maybe even you.
yeah you're right everything that happened before made
perfect sense but this is insane good catch i'm glad that
barry tells it to him straight i gotta get going the gps
yeah i know follow the signal got it oh it's the fact that
they don't fell like fade out or anything i'm here to help
you the thing is you need to get a grip all right you nagged
the way the real Barry does you know that well hey you know
be fair it's not my fault you think I'm annoying I don't
think you're annoying ah baby my imaginary friend just try
to stay on the ball here you need to do what Zane tells you
uh-huh he's been here for ages he's like the expert I'm
curious what scream is should we try it what if we get
ambushed though I'm scared anyway if This is insane and it's
all from your mind.
Never call yourself Alan.
We- Alan believe in you.
Alan, bye-bye for now.
Thank you, Vin!
We scream.
Don't shit a shitter, Al.
Deep down, you're always happy to see me.
Can't lie to yourself.
Know what I'm saying?
There must be a sucker for punishment.
You?
No, really?
And I always thought you went out of your way to avoid
trouble.
Thanks.
Thanks for that.
Don't be a shit shitter.
Flashlight.
Oh, do we get a better one here?
Like the torch?
Kick.
Alan.
Kick!
Oh, the lantern.
There it is.
No other words!
Oh, Alan recharge!
I can try the tremor one.
Give me a second.
We can go back, probably.
I know there was another box that dropped.
Where'd it go?
Wait, where'd my second box go?
Another box dropped.
I saw two of them.
Where'd it go?
A noclip out of existence?
Will you be playing Control?
I think you'd like the creepiness?
I think it'd be fine.
Uh, I...
I think I'll probably do it before Alan Wake, too.
Wait,
I think I actually did something.
Wait, what's happening?
Wait, uh, I think I...
You guys, I think...
Uh-oh.
Yowza.
I mean, I played Alan Wake 1, so I could play Alan Wake 2,
so...
Oh, gosh.
I have no flares.
FYI.
Boom!
Can I reach?
Can I snipe that?
Dang.
I think the signal's pointing towards that thing in the
distance.
Yeah.
That'd be the Biltmore sawmill.
How the hell do you know that?
I don't know anything you don't.
So why don't you ask yourself that?
Huh?
Maybe you saw a sign for it back in the real world.
You know what vibes he's giving me is in Twilight when Bella
was hallucinating Edward.
Like, she would get into dangerous situations because she
wanted to see Edward and was hallucinating him.
And he's the fact that he just kind of, like, shows up out
of nowhere and is just like, boom, boom, boom.
Oh.
Mama!
Hey, how?
I guess the pen is mightier.
If you complete that sentence, you're fired.
Mightier than the sword.
You're fired.
Aw.
No.
You can't fire him.
He...
He literally...
Is not real.
What am I hearing?
Oh, okay.
I guess I needed a...
It's
okay!
I'll probably die!
Oh,
I just reached a checkpoint.
Oh, dang it.
Dang it.
Let's make it all this sound!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, they really are like ghosts!
Boom!
Oh my god.
They're still coming after me.
Get them twice basically now!
Oh man, it's over.
I have to get them twice because they're gonna be shadows
and then I have to get them again.
I was like, real?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I got wombo comboed hard there.
Oh my god.
Oh!
They really do love to spawn behind me.
Don't they realize you're a ghost too?
I wish they would realize!
Did the fireworks even do anything?
I don't think it did.
Oh, geez.
This is stressing me out.
Boom!
What do you mean?
Hard to tell since he was flared.
Yeah, I threw out the flare because I was scared.
How do I switch the difficulty?
Oh my gosh!
Oh, oh gosh.
Where are they?
No!
I'm not doing a very good job at dodging anymore!
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm just gonna get these guys before I continue
onwards, because...
Oh my god.
Hello.
Okay, so I don't have to get them twice, it's just I can't
see them as well.
Is the issue.
I can't see them so well because they're shadowy ghost guys.
What if we go this way instead?
Alan believe.
It's tough to Alan believe.
Whoa!
Shit.
Oh, they respawn.
Oh, I'm so...
Oh, it's so over.
Oh my god.
Wait, what's happening?
Why am I in slow-mo?
Oh.
Oh, bad.
Oh, gosh.
Alan's struggle.
Wait, I thought there were...
Oh, I was gonna say I thought there were two flares.
In the visible man.
Sleeping in your bone.
Thoughts, not thoughts!
Where's the other guy at?
Oh.
Alan fireworks.
Just in case.
Alan tools.
Oh, not Alan tools yet.
Please.
Why did they have to drop everywhere?
So rude.
So, so rude.
It's just a bunch of ammo, isn't it?
Ah!
Shit, shit, shit!
Alan boom!
Oh, Alan!
Oh
my- I think there was one more guy though.
Oh, you.
Stop dodging me!
Alan,
not boom yet.
Uh, Alan lost.
Alan tools?
Uh, Alan go through.
Alan through?
Alan flash Oh my god Oh my god Oh my god Oh my god Oh my god
I like to imagine Alan calling out his
Alan's trash
Oh Oh Oh
There's no chance
point this DLC is utter chaos I know my goodness oh my god I
think it helps me focus too and I call out the moves when
I'm like when I'm like Alan boob it helps
I saw someone say I tried to warn her But not enough people
tried to warn me I don't think I saw I wish more people told
me that the DLCs were a doozy
Not enough one guys
Oh Okay can switch to easy for this is there like i mean i
did click normal i don't know if it would be the same or not
oh i have to restart i don't know how far we are in
no no no
at least here i'm blocked by the rock right you
guys all have the same outfit on it's It's really
embarrassing!
We'll go the right way this time.
Alan?
Fireworks!
Ow, Joe, Joe!
The fireworks did not work!
Alan dodge!
Alan, oh, but these guys are still gonna come after me.
Oh.
Who was throw in there?
Oh, there's still a shadow guy.
Okay, Alan go.
Alan reload.
I still have two flares now, so...
I get hurt by that.
I'm... Alan lost.
Ah!
There's another guy here?
The thing is, is I can't go too far or they'll start like
ambushing me, you know?
Visual glitch.
I only have two bullets left.
Uh-oh.
We're just going to keep going this way.
Wait, there's a light there.
Alan baboon.
I don't know if that did anything.
Oh, you know what?
Screw it.
I don't care.
Alan run to the light.
Please be a checkpoint.
It's a checkpoint!
Alan?
Turret?
Alan Bridge?
Okay.
We at least reached the checkpoint.
The other way it was a lie.
The other way was... was...
You know, you're gonna have to make your way across here.
The solution probably has something to do with those words.
No way.
Yeah, you should probably use them.
Your insight is staggering.
I think I'm getting ambushed.
What?
Oh, sorry, I thought I heard like a...
Like, it sounds like people are coming up behind me.
If you come up behind me.
They wouldn't be so rude to do that, were they?
Oh, shoot.
Come on.
There we go.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
See, this is the way things should be.
I give advice and you fall.
That's when things go right.
You get up to something on your own, that's when the trouble
starts.
That's horseshit.
I just saw another...
Figment.
Remember?
Wait.
Oh, okay, I'm here.
Some of my tools fell off!
Figment?
I think I need to use my shotgun though.
They wouldn't show up behind me, right?
Dark Souls would like to know your location.
Oh no.
Quake's own words.
Littering the landscape.
His books common and discarded.
Like mud beneath his feet.
Hardbacks.
Turned against him.
Trash.
I had seen weird transmissions of myself before.
Like that?
Book right there?
This?
The version of myself I saw now sounded insane.
Like a demented storyteller.
What's 9 for 10?
21.
Baby, thank you.
So now my books are even gonna be attacking me.
Sticks and stones may break my bow.
Oh my god.
They fall from the sky like crazy.
But my books would never hurt me!
Okay, I'm following the signal.
Oh, gosh.
It's raining!
Alan Wake!
Oh, okay.
What the hell is this?
Oh, the books!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
oh my gosh I'm trying not to get the don't don't get those
things please we have to be very careful there we have to be
very careful with what we filmed here okay they're gone
maybe all right this is a minefield for real
flare come on you gotta be careful those are bad words I
know Bad words Bad words Isn't that silly?
Enemy ravens Boom Tools I don't Oh my god The game actually
Like sabotages you The game actually Sabotages you Oh Oh
Oops.
Oh, my...
Is there a way to turn off auto-aim like that?
It's driving me insane.
How do I turn it off?
The game's...
Controls, maybe.
Direct aiming?
Disabled!
It's not even on!
Maybe...
Don't play with controller.
Was this game not made for...
controller?
Oh, direct equals manual.
Oh, okay.
Phew, shoo, shoo.
Is this?
It was.
It came out on Xbox originally.
Okay.
I'm so used to playing these kinds of games.
I know it's, like, more difficult.
I'm literally making it more difficult for myself.
But, like, also the sensitivity.
Oh, do you see this?
I don't think I can play with my mouse.
What the hell is this?
This is the sensitivity we'd be playing with.
Alright.
Anyway, let me move my...
Oh my gosh.
I can't move my mouse out of the way now.
Alright, back to the game.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I think I...
Guys, I'm so sorry.
I can't move my mouse now.
I'm really sorry.
Hold
on.
Maybe if I do this.
Oh.
I, it's, it, no matter.
I tried all tabbing into it.
It doesn't work.
Maybe.
Oh, if I do that.
No!
Why?
Oh, my gosh.
Alan glitch.
Okay.
Accompanied by a ghostly version of Barry, Wake attempts to
reach the sawmill.
I think I'm just gonna have to...
Okay.
Now there's two ghosts instead of...
Yeah, there's more than one.
There's...
There's Barry and there's me.
In the middle of the screen.
It's cute having a tiny minke on screen.
I'm glad you think so.
Those are bad words.
Bad words.
Ouch!
I can't move.
I'm stuck.
Hold on, I'm trying to get over here.
I think I should just run for it.
Honestly.
and also do you see that when i aim oh it's going where my
mouse is the game is actually trying to sabotage me okay
hold on i'm quitting i'm quitting the game real quick not
not quit quit but i need to quit i need to restart the game
it's like oh everything is bad everything is so bad
Everything is so bad!
Oh!
Okay.
Continue.
Let's see.
Alright.
Do you guys want video commentary?
Direct aiming.
Enabled.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't think Ravenholm was this man.
I think.
Oh, no!
Wait!
It did it again though!
It aimed at the enemy!
It didn't aim...
Oh.
Okay.
What the... Oh, sorry.
The word hurt me.
Those are bad words.
Bad words.
Ow,
shit!
I got a stinking achievement.
It's so funny.
Stop, please.
I'm gonna die.
I'm about to die.
I'm about to die!
Okay, I just need to take it easy right here.
Okay, we're in a wall, so...
I just need to take it easy for a second.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Alright.
Just need to take it easy.
Don't fall off!
Did...
Oh my god.
It's okay.
The earth shook.
Street lights pushed themselves up to the ground, flickering
madly.
It's Spade Spark.
In the shadow's wake saw far too many seconds.
Go Pat!
I don't know who's in the superb owl.
Who is in there?
Adolf, yeah.
I say the same thing.
Barry!
This is just too weird.
You're weird.
Thank you, Barry.
Is all this really coming out of my head?
That's just the way this place is, Al.
All that random stuff in your head?
No!
How are each other?
Where are they?
Oh.
Yeah.
I just hear them dying behind me.
Oh, shoot.
I see these big guys.
Yeah.
You too.
I gotta like, kind of Get them underneath.
I gotta like blind them while they're underneath the thing,
you know?
Lead them into there.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Never mind.
I'm just gonna get to you.
There.
Oh, yeah.
Ouch, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Come here.
Oh, no, no.
Dig it.
Me right now.
Oh, geez.
Oh my god.
My depth perception.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Don't don't don't!
I think I got it.
Oh.
Oh, yeah, the words, they hurt.
The earth shook.
Oh.
Streetlights pushed themselves up to the ground, slickering
madly and spitting spark.
And the shadow's wings saw far.
Too many figures have had the ear.
Okay, this is just too weird.
You're weird.
Barry, is all this really coming out of my head?
That's just the way this place is, Al.
All that random stuff in your head?
Imagination.
Sorry, I gotta go!
This way?
Oh, shoot!
Did you just see him fly?
That's so funny.
Oh my gosh.
Yes!
Yes, sir.
I think I'm going the right way.
Oh shoot.
Yeah!
Not yeah!
Just go, go, go, go, go, go.
No!
You can come here!
Oh, no, no, actually, don't.
No, my.
Okay, I think I made it.
Oh, my gosh.
I did.
I made it.
Oh, my God.
We just gotta keep going.
The whole thing is just keep moving.
Don't stop.
Like, you can't focus on enemies for too long.
Because they just don't stop.
They just don't stop.
Wheels?
Oh!
I need to get that door open before you can get into the
warehouse.
That's the way forward.
If I'm making this up, why is it so complicated?
Yeah, that's why I'm wondering.
Because you're a complicated man, and no one understands
you.
But I'm talking...
Yeah, Barry.
Just blip out of existence, please.
Why is this so complicated?
You know, Alan Wake, I have a lot of questions for you.
Oh.
What just exploded over there?
Oh, whoops.
Can we start over?
I'm stuck.
I'm literally trapped.
Oh, shoot.
My car is broken, though.
Can we start over?
I didn't know what this was.
Oh, my God.
And there's guys.
Just kill me.
Please just kill me.
My car got stuck.
I have to restart Redo Redo You need to get that door open
before you can get into the warehouse.
That's the way forward If I'm making this up.
Why is it so complicated?
Because you're a complicated man and no one understands you
but I'm talking Oh, I think I There's like a thing over
there.
I think I accidentally...
I didn't realize, because that's what exploded I think.
I think I accidentally did it.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god,
oh my god.
Oh shoot, please!
Ah!
Oh my god, oh my god!
It's a death, it's a death, it's a death for me, no!
Oh my god!
I was holding A after redoing it again.
What the hell is all of this, you guys?
You need to get that door open before you can get into the
way.
Stop, I didn't even move!
You jumped and it was your fault!
Why is it so complicated?
Because you're a complicated man and no one understands you.
Don't try to fight yet.
Yeah, I think I learned that.
I tried before.
I just tried now because the first time I didn't really have
a fair fight.
But this time, we're just going to go for it.
I'm just gonna go...
Wait, is this where I'm supposed to go?
Oh, jeez!
I'm stuck?
Okay!
Heels?
Oh, wheels.
Another car.
Pump?
What's up?
I forgot there's guys here too.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna...
Leave me alone.
Getting back in.
I'm getting back in the car.
And I'm going.
Getting back in the car and I'm going.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, so true.
Please get in.
No, please.
Oh, I can't get in.
That's right!
Oh,
that's not a, that's not an explodey barrel.
Oh, that's fine.
We'll get more batteries.
How do I get up there?
Alan jump.
Uh, Alan find a way around.
Alan explore.
Uh.
That was badass, thank you.
That was like the perfect way to use the flare gun, no?
That was like the perfect way to use it.
I don't think I could have gotten a better shot unless I had
gotten that last guy.
I didn't think everybody would die.
I didn't think I would hit them all.
Flare.
Hunt?
What the hell does that mean?
What does hunt mean?
You're gonna give me only one?
Stenji.
Oh, maybe like the hunting rifle.
Probably.
Right?
Hunting rifle?
Hunting rifle.
It was it?
Oh, it was.
It was.
I'm so scared for a second.
Wait, but...
5 versus how many bullets do I have with the shotgun?
11.
I just got more shotgun ammo too.
I was going to lose it.
Especially because something happened and like disappeared.
Yeah, I thought like I was about to get hunted or something.
Oh, there's our checkpoint.
Nice.
Hey, what are you up to?
I thought this was my side of the bed.
Oh.
That's it.
Just thinking about my hot wife.
Don't mind me.
Oh, no.
What?
Surrounded by enemies.
Wake had nowhere to run.
I'm so sick of you.
I might.
I
need to switch to you.
I have nothing.
I have...
Oh my god.
I can't even dodge.
Oh, what the hell is happening?
Oh my god.
I'm about to fall off.
Guys...
I don't think the DLC is very fun.
Hey, what are you up to?
I thought this was my side of the bed.
Guys, I think the DLC is hard.
Guys, sure does it look like it?
Hold on.
Change the easy.
I think I would have to restart the whole game.
I would have to restart.
You don't understand.
If I change the easy, I have to go through everything.
all over again.
Second DLC story is better on easy.
It will probably be better paced.
Oh, man.
Trying to decide what to do.
I know.
I feel really... I feel deep enough in it that I don't want
to quit.
You know what I mean?
But I'm at the same time.
I'm like, man.
Oh, geez.
I'm almost done, I am.
How much further do I have to go?
I don't want to be, like, feeling so frustrated because I
don't think that's fun to watch, you know what I mean?
But at the same time, I don't want to quit because I am
stubborn like that.
If I set my mind to do something, I'm like, I want to see it
through.
But at the same time, I'm like, God dang.
Okay, what I'll try to do is I'll try to run through and
flare and do the climb and run.
Shut up.
Shut up!
Oh my god.
What's happening?
Shut up!
Ouch!
Shut up.
I am, might become the Joker.
Joker.
No, no, no, no, no!
No!
He
entered the trap surrounded by enemies.
Wake it no where you run.
I'm so sick of you!
And I'm so sick of you!
Drudge!
Josh!
Allen!
Allen run and Allen dodge and- Oh shh!
I- Allen get completely stuck behind a pole.
Minto, you want to know how I got these scars?
Let's listen to my wife and be it calmed by the sound of a
woman.
Hey, what are you up to?
I thought this was my side of the bed.
I'm sorry.
The abrupt cutoff.
The abrupt cutoff of the...
Of the...
Oh shit.
Of the song was too funny.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay.
I don't think I'm like...
Okay, come on, please.
Please, please, please, God.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please.
Oh, thank goodness.
They can't climb too, can they?
Or...
Oh, I got the checkpoint!
Okay, nice.
Oh.
Heavy-duty lantern.
I'm holding B?
Or is that what I already have?
Is mine heavy duty?
Is it...
No, please.
I'm holding down.
There we go.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Flare.
Oh, that's never a good sound, is it?
Barry, I could really use your help!
a single flare a single flare
I'm looking if there's any other words no other words I'm
just I just don't want to go inside I think I'm just here I
see him his like his musk his aura is so strong it's seeping
through man I hate this Alan guy he freaking sucks Alan wake
up Wait, don't!
Oh!
Is that...
Where is he?
Wait, is that not him?
Right here?
I hit it out of desperation.
Is that it?
Hold on.
That was it?
There's a clock!
Ah!
Oh, I heard it earlier.
Like at the beginning of the game, I didn't realize it was a
collectible.
Oh, interesting.
Alan Kitch.
Oh.
I'm just gonna quarter myself and wait for them to come to
me.
Ah!
Oh god!
Make it climb!
Hello,
what's it called guys again?
The salary man.
Oh, my
God.
Oh, they can climb.
Oh,
my God.
Wait.
Strong.
Too strong.
Okay, let's switch back to this.
Oh, my God.
You scared me.
Well, my allergies are...
I guess I need to say flares.
You scared me.
You scared me, Perry.
This place is setting off my allergies.
Um...
My allergies, so true.
My Alan Wake allergies.
Chain reaction.
Yeah, it was kind of awesome.
I'm following the GPS signal.
Follow the GPS signal, they said.
Just keep following the GPS signal.
Oh, we got another memory.
We get another bridge.
And another bridge.
I'm allergic to hack riders.
Uh, where did it go?
Okay.
Memory.
Is it my wife?
It's my wife.
Stop it!
They're waiting for us downstairs.
We don't have time for Alan.
Alan!
I knew she wasn't really here, but she still made my
heartache.
I had saved Alice.
But I wasn't even sure when that happened.
Was it days ago?
weeks, longer, I had no way of knowing.
Oh, yeah, this is why.
What is happening?
Oh, this thing.
Okay?
Oh, uh, uh.
Whoa, that's fast.
Guess you gotta run, Al.
Oh, thanks!
We gotta push this first.
There we go.
Alan's a dog.
Running, running, running, running, running, running.
I bought.
Thanks, Barry.
Alan, I'm trying to feel bad for you, but it ain't easy.
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me right now?
Wait.
Am I stuck on this thing?
Oh.
Wait.
Ah!
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna fall off this thing.
I thought for some reason it was gonna be like a moving
contraption.
You know what I mean?
Where you dodge the enemies while it continues onwards.
to someplace else I don't know why I assume that I was just
like okay we're gonna keep going down from this point we're
gonna keep moving to the it literally stops right there like
I could see it I can literally see where it's supposed to
stop I knew she wasn't really here but she still knew my
heartache I had saved Dallas but I wasn't even sure when
that happened was it days ago weeks longer I had no way of
knowing.
Everybody's talking over each other again.
Alright.
Let's switch to my...
Revolver.
Alright.
Hey!
Ah!
Dodge!
Where'd that guy go?
Wait, where'd he go?
Oh.
I did it?
Okay.
I did it.
He just left.
Maybe he ran off the side of the building like I did.
Oh.
How romantic.
This music is killing me.
Hey, lover.
Come here.
I could only hope that Alice was all right.
I didn't know what happened to her after she left the dark
place.
Oh my gosh, it's so romantic.
Yes, let us be guided by thoughts of our world.
Yes!
Oh.
Zane?
Is that you?
Inside?
In here?
Ouch.
Hey, hold that pose.
That was a good one.
Like this?
He's not doing anything.
No, that's too much.
He's just...
Tough.
You know how people go for those dangerous...
He's not doing anything different.
Oh, come on.
You write about terrible things all the time.
People want to think that you're intimately familiar with
them.
You kill Casey in this book.
You need to look a little bit like a murderer.
Oh, that's good.
Do that again.
He hasn't changed at all.
He hasn't changed anything.
You know, I wasn't sure about to be here before, but I was
wrong.
It looks good on you.
Oh.
Okay, I think we're going to...
Alan, bad boy.
I want to get out of this suit.
Hey, things are looking up.
danger is sexy oh oh that's so that was when i was still
working when i felt like a real writer instead of a fraud it
was a good memory i wished i hadn't seen it wait can i get
behind there i hear another clock somewhere you hear it is
it inside checkpoint reached oh my goodness can't see
anything I think.
Okay.
Oh, this is kind of scary.
I'm just gonna run for it.
Oh!
I'm in my apartment!
Ow!
Swah!
Whoa.
Oh, I hear it.
It's right there.
Yeah, we're home again!
Wait, is our tiny...
Aww, we can't see our tiny washing machine.
This is like a final boss, they're giving me so much stuff.
Guys, this was tough, but if this is closer to the end...
We almost... we... you know, I'm proud of us.
Stick it through it.
Oh, I... Zane?
Oh, it's Zane!
You made it.
This area of the dark place is calmer, at least for the time
being.
We can talk here, but we don't have much time Zane how do I
get out of here?
That's what you face.
That's you even as we speak Darkness Darkness coming Swept
him away lost He knew he knew he couldn't hold on he knew
there was no way out.
Oh, no, I'm right here.
That's not me It's just I don't know an echo a hallucination
the dark presence the dark presence is not responsible for
this you are Me?
I suck.
Oh, we're like out of our apartment now.
No!
You get swallowed up in the rising tide of darkness.
It was coming.
Shut up!
Yeah, shut up!
No!
Alan, you must be.
Just ignore him!
Swept away by the gathering insanity.
Zane was gone.
Wait could feel the pressure, gnawing at his mind.
The darkness wasn't so bad.
It was in him.
Why don't you just ignore him?
It was just too hard to think.
It can't.
Couldn't make sense of it.
Couldn't.
You wanted to go with the flow.
Stop thinking and just let go.
Just be chill, Alan.
Just be chill.
Are we fighting Mecha Robot?
It's Mecha Robot.
Alan Wake.
Destroy the TVs!
Okay.
Where are they?
Like, that guy?
Okay.
Wait, I think I go down.
What the?
What do I hear behind me?
You hear that?
I think it's downstairs, probably.
Oh.
Oh, it's real dark down there.
Guys, that don't look so good.
them from here?
Why does it do fall damage to me?
Holy cow.
Ouch.
Oh, there's guys in here!
Ouch!
I was hoping that...
Oh my god.
There's so much happening.
I was hoping I'd be...
The scope of this horror was unmasked.
it would have been so much easier blocked by the pole is
what I was trying to say let's get ah die stop it oh I died
my eyes oh the smoke is still here from the fight that I was
just doing
okay okay I think what we'll do is this wait And then run
over here.
Oh, shoot.
Run behind the pole?
Ah, I can't see anything.
My eyes.
My heckin' eyes.
Oh, my God.
This guy's here, too.
Okay.
Oh, there's another guy.
Oh, I got it, though.
See that?
With one player?
I took out the whole thing.
I might be pretty good.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just trying to move.
I hit a barrel that I didn't know was freaking possessed.
I didn't know it was possessed.
I backed into a stinkin' barrel.
Alan Tripp.
Alright.
Wait.
There's another guy, right?
Oh, shoot.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm like trapped.
Trying to use the things to my advantage.
Where?
Wait, where?
Oh, you?
Okay, let's get this too, since, uh, alright.
Okay, I didn't get it one try this time, but, you know, it
is what it is.
Oh my gosh.
I don't want to waste it, though.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, there's another guy coming.
I see you.
Oh, my God.
Ouch!
I'm doing my best, guys.
Holy cow.
Okay.
I think there was something here.
Revolver.
Okay, revolver, I'm wrong.
Alright.
Let's go in.
Ouch!
They just start moving!
Oh my god, please!
Thank you!
Goodness gracious!
Wait, was there...
Oh, batteries, yes, yes, please.
Please pick up the batteries.
Alright.
We'll kind of like hide behind the bear.
here and hope that I can get a good spot.
Okay, no, I can't get a good spot.
I'm literally shining my flashlight on it, but it refuses to
believe.
There we go.
All right.
I think.
Uh, all right, all right.
There's something out.
Oh, the barrel!
The heckin' barrel.
All right.
There's more?
Or...
Something.
Oh, something else.
Yeah.
This guy.
Alright.
Let's clear out stuff before we...
I'm going in!
Oh, what am I supposed to be seeing?
The barrel!
Oh my god.
Where'd the barrel go?
I'm stuck.
Okay.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I don't have.
Please.
Oh my god, oh my god, please.
Get the freaking barrel.
Get the barrel!
Alan, please!
Oh my god.
Okay, all right.
Get this guy, get this guy.
Oh,
I reached the checkpoint!
Oh, thank goodness.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do here.
Uh, besides just...
Oops, I put in too many batteries.
Pick up the flare, pick up the flare, pick up the batteries,
pick up the flare.
Okay, Alan yelled.
Alan does everything.
This is literally me the entire DLC.
That was me the entire DLC.
So in the end, I don't even like...
I don't even get to get to release myself.
I fall prey to the darkness.
Because I'm stupid.
Me playing the DLC.
The Geek Squad.
Release yourself how?
We were listening to...
What's his name?
Oh my god.
I did it!
I beat the special episode one!
Feels like that was a skippable DLC.
I know!
We didn't learn anything.
We just learned that we were still trapped.
I'm skipping the audio.
A friend indeed is what I gotta...
We didn't learn anything.
You learned pain.
Oh my god.
Holy cow.
We learned that the dark place sucks ass.
There's cheeks in here.
Can't.
Easy mode.
You can't, you can't.
Oh, jeez.
Oh, Alan learns.
They should call it the dork place.
The second one is easier?
Okay, thank you.
Oh, maybe call it here.
No, no, I think we can do this second one.
Let me grab a snack real quick.
I used up so much.
You know what?
I got a donut earlier.
I'm going to go get it.
I'm going to go get my donut.
I'll be right back.
I was going to save this for tomorrow.
I was like a treat to myself.
And I think I deserve it right now.
And then later, I'm going to get something else delicious.
Alan's stress eat.
I don't stress eat usually.
But I feel I'm getting shaky, so I think I need some sugar.
Global Reset.
This episode is Peak Sam Lake Cinema.
Is it special too?
Okay, good.
I'm excited then.
You usually let yourself get shaky way more often.
I just don't tell you guys.
I just haven't mentioned it for a little while.
But maybe it has happened less often.
Oh, I think that episode, like, I didn't have to redo so
many parts over and over.
Like, you know.
It was just the stress of it all happening.
Like, you know, I would have to be like, Alan do this, Alan
do that, Alan.
Like, I was like, holy cow.
Sugar and nap break.
How are you doing today, Minto?
I'm good.
I pushed through.
I did.
I said I won't give up.
That was close, though.
What kind of donut?
It's a chocolate glazed donut.
I remember thinking that the first DLC was kind of nuts when
I first played it.
Is that like how Nightmare Mode kind of is?
Or worse?
Or is Nightmare Mode worse, I mean?
Not the DLC worse.
Nah, well, thank you so much for the thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Nightmare Mode is worse.
I absolutely rage quit the first DLC during the invisible
guy's part Nightmare difficulty is like you pretty much have
to dodge or you'll die Oh god
Oh my thing is is I like games I like to play games you know
I'm not the best at games but I still enjoy myself but I am
not sweaty with games You know what I mean?
Like, I'm here to vibe and enjoy myself.
And if there's a bit of a challenge, like, I'm okay with
that, usually.
Um, but I, I'm like, you know, some people are, like, very
serious about how they play a game.
And for me, I'm just like, la la la.
Immersive gameplay, the suffering happens directly to the
player.
I feel like I got brain damage for real.
Do you know that?
Do you know that one sound?
Like, that's...
used in videos sometimes.
I actually don't know what it's from, but it's like a girl
singing and she's like La la la la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la and then
they just start screaming.
That's me.
I feel like that's me in these types of games.
At least you're not one of those people that throw their
controllers against the wall.
Yeah, I don't do that.
Alan Wake was their first try at story overshooting.
They got the balance right later games.
I feel like this game has so much action.
I feel like this game has a ton of action.
Can I pay you to throw your controller?
No, I need it.
I need my controller.
All right.
I think I'm ready to...
Actually...
a water bottle real quick.
One second.
One second, one second.
Okie dokie.
Let's get through episode... DLC episode 2, shall we?
On easy mode.
Easy mode.
No scatter!
Come back!
Alan hydrated.
Alan drink.
Alan kumpai!
I mean, did you enjoy the main story?
I did!
I really like this game.
It's challenging sometimes, but I did enjoy myself.
I did think, you know, even when I complained about parts of
the game, like, oh, I thought it was too repetitive, this
and that, and this and that.
It's not me saying that I disliked it.
I did still like it.
to the rider previously on Alan Wake it's not a lake it's an
ocean after saving my wife from the mysterious dark presence
I found myself trapped in the dark place imagination can be
the enemy here a nightmarish world that exists somewhere
beyond the shores I could have just watched this just do
what Zane tells you follow the signal I could have just done
all of I just could have just watched this I made my way
across its ever-shifting landscape trying to reach
There's a town in Canada called Ninto?
No way.
Whoa.
It's all in your head.
You've been making it up.
Who was that?
Was that Barry?
Really?
Your delusions are out of control.
Leave my brain alone.
Flip!
You know reality's different here?
Yeah.
See what I mean?
Ow!
Oh, Barry's actually trying to help us out.
No.
Well, you're gonna have to find your way out of there.
I'll wait.
Just remember, you're still in the dark place.
You know that, right?
I don't want to alarm you, pal, but it's sink or swim time.
I get it, I get it.
Wow, they really just kind of put you right back in.
Huh.
Barry was right.
Time was running out.
Everything I saw was a dark, twisted version of reality
based on my memories and thoughts.
I wonder how easy mode will be.
I'm very curious.
What is this?
Oh.
Turn the pole.
Oh, oh.
Crumble.
Oh.
Um.
It was here.
Is there somewhere I needed to go?
I don't have a flashlight.
Spoiler.
Easiest, easier than normal.
No way!
Find a way to bury.
What the heck am I supposed to be doing here?
Do I need to, like, swing...
I think you gotta swing it!
You, I, I, shut up!
That's exactly what I was about to say!
He stole my line!
I was in the...
I said, I think I need to...
He stole my line!
Backseating Barry over here.
Goodness gracious.
I'm not gonna have to go through the maze again, am I?
I had to accept it If all of this was from my mind Then I
was the one making all this happen I was literally fighting
myself It was a moment of clarity Yes Oh Are they gonna come
from up there
But they have no gun Checkpoint reached Heavy duty lantern
Surprise?
Is it the ultimate weapon that will destroy everything in
one hit?
Yeah, too active of an imagination.
He can't help it, guys.
He's a writer.
Oh, Sorry, visual glitch happened.
Retouch.
I heard cram bone instead of crumble.
Why'd you hear that?
What do you...
Do I have a gun yet?
No.
Wait, what's...
What am I climbing?
I guess it happened on the outside?
Oh, here it is, yeah.
You'll start this mission with no weapons or tools.
Your code name will be naked awake.
I finished myself.
All I had wanted was to save Alice.
After that, a part of me had been ready to just give in and
die.
But I hadn't given up.
Thomas Sane had reached me.
I had run across a nightmare.
Ready to give in and die.
He kept telling me I was sinking, going too deep.
I wasn't sure if he meant the dark place or insanity.
Unfortunately for Alan, the person you battled, I have to
get so hard as his ultimate.
So...
Yeah.
Guys...
I'm...
Back in the maze!
Pump.
Oh!
That's what they mean by pump.
Oh, because I think I saw a pump before and I was like, what
the heck does that mean?
I'm hearing strange sounds around me.
Do you guys hear all that?
I'm hearing something like over here.
It's all the guys Viking stuff.
What is this?
Oh, it's the Night Springs video game!
That's what I was hearing.
Oh my god.
Pump it.
Pop it.
Kill it.
Eat it.
Cannibal it.
Oh!
Nice job, Al!
So, you really are nuts, huh?
Let's face it, we always knew this was coming.
Are there enemies?
I guess, but I actually feel pretty rational.
All things considered.
Are there enemies?
Crazy people don't know they're crazy.
That's where they're crazy.
Hey, check out the light show behind the lodge.
Whoa!
That's Zane's light.
Yeah, you're done sinking now.
That means he's just about caught up with you.
You better go talk to him.
That's Zane's light.
Cannibalism mentioned.
So many fireworks.
Lots of fireworks here.
Nice.
Oh.
This guy is so annoying.
I'm in a self-deprecating contest with Alan Wake.
Oh, hell yeah.
Remember this, Al?
The music is so funny.
You guys hear it?
It's so funny.
Wait, I should just do, like, all the fireworks, huh?
They're not stopping, so...
Hey!
Wee!
Why
are these flying around?
They're not possessed.
By
your own imagination?
It's like your greatest power turned against you.
Very sharp.
That's very deep, but I'm a little busy not dying over here.
Wait, there's only... Can I... Where's the revolver?
Oh, right here.
Surrounded by the enemies and deafened by the noise.
Whoa!
Ouch!
I'm running over here.
I can't imagine this in...
and not...
in like, you know...
normal or other anything else.
It's over.
Just imagining it like...
You can get inside now, Al.
This guy.
It's amazing.
I know!
I love Easy Mode!
Oh, Easy Mode.
Easy Mode, my beloved.
I feel like there's pretty few times that I choose Easy
Mode.
I hope you guys don't mind.
See how?
This is classic you.
Classic V.
It's so Which is just a memory.
Even your memories are complicated.
Oh, Zane!
Uh, yeah.
So I guess you're gonna need to talk to Zane out there now
that he's actually here.
I'm just gonna, you know, let you non-imaginary people talk
in peace.
Okay, thank you.
You're not coming?
Nah, that wasn't good much.
Very...
Yeah, you're moving up in the world, buddy.
Oh.
Okay, let's go.
Barry, you're not going to come with us?
Same.
You have done well, Alan.
Now I can accompany you.
You're trapped in your own dream.
You must wake yourself up, but first, you have to reach
yourself.
You have to reach myself.
The cabin!
Yes, my cabin.
It will not be easy.
Your cabin.
Your previous work can help you.
I still have some pages of your manuscript left.
Words like that have power here.
So you're going to...
You're now gonna...
You're gonna accompany us?
With your big massive light?
Who will explain the obvious to us now?
What's he gonna do?
Nothing.
Clear!
I sometimes... I kind of feel like Card Capture Sakura.
You know what I mean?
The lighthouse?
It's very appropriate.
I can help you reach it.
But after that, you will be on your own.
I can only enter the cabin now.
The dark presence made sure of that on our last encounter.
You are facing yourself, the parts of your mind that are
hard to control.
This is not a fight anyone else can win for you.
Guys, let's do rock, paper, scissors.
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot!
I bet you all picked paper.
Wait.
Scissor.
Yeah, you pick scissors.
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
Rock, paper, scissors, bolt.
Okay, that's different.
You thought of it.
Wait, that's so funny, we have to get rid of the...
Wait, float?
Oh, like a floaty.
I was glad to have Zane waking in this place.
He knew the terrain such as it was.
But a part of me wondered if he was not a human anymore.
After so many years in this place.
I never learned.
Wait.
It's like destined that one will always fall.
That's fine.
Wait, the cabin is literally right here?
Oh no, we have to reach the lighthouse.
Just kidding.
Oh.
The world was tilted.
It was turning upside down.
Wake was lost.
He would fall.
He couldn't tell which way was up.
He would die there.
Torn apart by the whirlwind.
Uh.
It does say this way.
This way.
It's giving me arrows.
It's giving me...
There's gamer paint.
Zade, are you familiar with big chungus?
What if, what if Alan Wake used his powers for good, like
fan fiction and stuff, you know?
The wind was picking up.
Wake was too high.
Too high.
At this height, the water would be like hitting concrete.
Oh, woo, it's crazy.
Oh, Jesus.
You can't want me dead this bad.
The storm was coming.
It would throw him off.
Bridge!
Oh, uh, wait, wait, wait.
Can I make, I can make this.
Huh?
Nice.
Ah!
Holy cow!
You're no milker.
Where is that big boy hiding?
The storm spun him around.
It was made of darkness.
He'd seen what it could do.
It swept everything.
I would have to make my way through the swirling waves.
It reminded me of the dark presence.
Oh, just a revolver.
But it could still kill me.
It could still kill you.
If you die in the game, you die in real life.
Wait!
Oh my gosh, the bed!
The bed?
Okay.
Oh, my eyes.
Alan clap.
The game is real.
phase yeah he's not see all you have to do is not listen to
the annoying guy on the tv just do what you want imagine
this with voice controls if this could be a fun like they it
would be pretty fun to have like an alan wake typing of the
dead kind of type thing you know oh i
think this level maybe didn't need easy mode you know what i
mean Well, I don't know how it would have been.
They focused on the lighthouse.
If you can reach it, you will find the cabin.
It could have been really bad.
Who knows?
It's to be expected.
You're struggling to reclaim yourself.
The landscape reflects that strain.
But each step takes you closer.
Scribble thoughts.
The thing that came to the city that fends out the darkness.
Yeah.
Is there anything else?
revolver ammo okay reach the lighthouse at least we're not
really in the woods anymore now that i knew what i was
facing the environment became even wilder and stranger oh no
like it was no longer even bothering to pretend that things
were normal are you saying you're regretting switching to
easy no i'm just saying that i think the other chapter was
or the other chapter previous like from what I had done.
You know, I haven't, I'm not very far in this one, but it
seemed more intensive than...
What's a roll?
I just ate one of those.
I grabbed a roll when I got some water.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Overload, let's, let's roll.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
I would like to use the roll!
I would like to use the roll, please.
I'm just bad at it.
Just whispered that.
Kind of cool you can hear the liquid inside them.
I know, right?
I would like to use it.
I'm just not good at timing it.
There's so many of them.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, there it is.
There they are.
There's one guy left.
Oh, uh, I think, uh, oh, here we go.
Not me!
Ouch!
That guy!
Oh,
like it targeted me.
Um, oh, there's More guys.
Oh shoot.
Dude.
Big boy!
You coming!
Now they're only sending like one big guy in and rather than
like, rather than like 15 of them at once.
Okay.
That was intense.
SpongeBob pants.
Okay.
Yeah.
SpongeBob.
Big Pat.
Spend the boat.
Man, it's okay.
Let's keep going.
Maybe it's 15 and normal.
It probably would have been.
I probably would have been like...
I'm cruising right now.
Hole.
Oh, oh, oh, no.
Why did that happen?
Can I go in?
Oh.
Oh, I can't.
Okay.
Oh, I should reload.
Okay, there we go.
There's a hole here.
It's gone now.
Ouch!
These stank and words, man.
Can I crank it?
Can I get it back up?
I'm not supposed to go up here, right?
Hello?
I guess we'll do the fireworks.
See what happens.
Oh!
Oh, it's funky.
Whoa!
Unlimited flares?
Ah!
Oh!
Wow!
Still unlimited?
Amazing.
Hmm.
Uh-huh.
The cart.
The random shopping cart.
Oh, puts the lotion on its skin or else it gets the hose
again.
Oh, puts the flare on the hole or else it gets the flare
I reached the checkpoint.
Is this the well-lit room area?
Or this is the tunnel to the well.
I can't see anything.
Oh, I'm supposed to go over here.
That doesn't sound like a good sound.
Sound like a pretty bad sound.
Oh, geez.
He came up on me first.
Pretty cool.
Am I lost in here?
Oh, golly.
Oh, it's you!
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look, it's so noisy.
Ah!
Anyway.
Huh.
That's the well-lit tunnel.
To the well-lit room.
The...
Quake was forced to run through a maze, hopelessly sprinting
in the wheel.
Never getting anywhere.
His life in miniature.
It was useless.
Oh
Not a maze.
Oh, it is a wheel.
Oh my gosh It's a wheel
I'm a little I'm a hamster Wow, look at that.
Oh This way yet Hamptor.
Wait.
Wait, it's getting low again.
We just give it enough time?
Hamptor.
Oh,
what the heck?
Oh, they're giant!
Into the water?
Oof.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, that scared me!
before ghost Alan ghost ghost ghost wake comes in geez oh
okay we're still going uh not this way uh this way
oh no can I help you with anything oh no I'm okay thank you
let's have a look at your head Mr Wake
the door is open I need more light The door is open!
This part's cool, I like this.
This part's really cool.
I gotta wait for them to roll.
And then we follow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The lights are starting to go out though.
Down here?
Uh...
Where did I come from?
Okay, oh, there, that's where I came from, so I go into
here.
Okay.
Ouch!
How am I supposed to avoid this?
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Ouch!
Is this a thing out open?
No?
Oh, I think I'll go through here?
It's so trippy.
It is!
They really locked in after the first one.
Yeah, this one is very...
like atmospheric and fun and yeah i'm liking this a whole
lot okay wait oh i thought that was a ladder oh my gosh oh
oh oh oh oh oh wait where do i go into here okay i need to
like not die i think i need to jump oh i died we made it to
here i think i need to hurry i think that's my that's like
oh my gosh so that i'm not jumping you know what i mean like
wait did i go this way
like how am i supposed to avoid fall damage here i don't
really understand what they are expecting of me
see it's like quite literally impossible Oh, that makes
sense.
I'm impatient.
I'm ready to go to the next row.
Alan, wait.
Ugh, fine.
It's like hard.
I can't tell.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Okay, nice.
Alan wait, Alan patient.
Alan be patient.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, no, I slipped!
Alan?
Alan, don't slip off the edge, buddy.
Like, what are you doing here?
Oh.
I thought that was, I thought you would...
Just hold on.
Alan slip and slide, Alan stumble.
If I stand against the wall, it should be okay.
Alright.
We're gonna be lying down a little bit.
Okay, we're really short.
Okay, here we go.
Um...
Do I open this?
No.
Oh!
It opens itself!
The Wellit Room!
Is that gonna stop this ride?
An elevator?
Sure, why not?
Next stop is sanity.
You're doing well.
Keep going.
Thank you!
I like saying.
It's a dream.
This is a vast place.
Home to forces and beings that are completely alien.
The dark presence yes.
I don't know what happened to it after your final encounter
Is there any way out of here?
Sometimes transmissions can be sent between worlds.
You've done this yourself But to actually leave the dark
place.
I haven't found a way.
Yeah, I think what did you think?
What did you expect him to have done it if he knew?
We'll get you out of here Zane
Stucky's gas station Oh my gosh!
Not something I particularly wanted to see, but obviously I
wasn't the one in the driver's seat.
Stucky's gas station!
It's been so long!
Wait.
We have 13?
Hello.
Reload.
Another memory made real.
The other memory made real.
Wake would never make it.
The insanity he was facing was already a part of the- Never
think of Shaka.
His own doing.
He couldn't possibly win.
Oh nice.
He didn't even want to!
What?
I want to win.
This is the first place we were on.
Nordic walking.
Welcome.
Yeah.
We'll go with the...
I feel like...
I kind of want the shotgun just because we have so much ammo
for it, but at the same time...
Hello?
At least the...
lighthouse was much closer now i would have to make my way
up there somehow boom boom boom you make my heart go oh my
god oh my god there were so few guys i love easy mode there
was just three guys So, oh, that's not anything.
That was so awesome.
Oh.
Wait, the deer now, do you guys see that?
The deer is now two-headed.
Oh, wait.
I think it's two deer.
Oh, there's a deer up there!
Ew.
I like the visual storytelling here.
Like, everything's kind of gone crazy and weird.
You know, it's fun to see.
Oh, dear!
Boom.
Go back to my revolver and save the ammo for that.
Wire, wire, wire.
Wire, wire, pants on fire.
What does that do?
Oh, there's a button.
Okay.
There was no power to the log lift.
Loglift.
Wire.
Jaguar.
Oops.
Oh, oh, whoa.
Oh, my gosh.
Stop it.
Where the other guy go?
Oh, there was one more.
Oh, well, there's a guy down here.
Oh, there's a guy down here.
Who did I just avoid?
Oh, just you?
Oh.
Does this deal?
Uh, let's get the wire.
Eh.
Maybe that's it.
Oh, wire?
Start.
Eee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee.
Eee-ee-ee-ee.
You dodged the word damage.
Is that what it was?
Huge if real.
That's so funny
Alan run Alan use Great stream, Vito I'm having a lot more
fun So I'm glad
Before I was like Man, this is a tough play But now I'm
enjoying myself Okay Before I was just stressed.
Now I'm like...
I honestly think there's nothing wrong with like...
Yeah, uh...
I think it was Alan Wake.
There was something that had like a...
An easy mode just so you could enjoy the story.
It might have been Alan Wake.
Can't remember.
There was definitely something there.
Soma?
No, I haven't played Soma yet.
One day I probably will.
Expedition 33 did.
Yeah, I don't necessarily see any harm in that.
The part of you that is in control is in the cabin, dreaming
and insane.
To me.
I don't think I like that.
I'm dreaming and insane.
You represent the part of Alan Wake that is capable of
rational thought and planning, which is why I'm talking to
you.
If that part can regain control, then you have a chance of
making it.
to give in there's comfort in the oblivion of dreams you
represent the part that isn't ready to quit and die yeah
wait are you telling me i'm not real you're as real as
anything else in this place well that's a buzz in my hand so
there are two of me yes yes and the one you called mr
scratch he's me as well no zane are you playing some kind of
game with me i am not the author of your story How can you
say that when you wrote that page about me and the clicker?
Yeah, it wasn't one of my pages.
You directed me to it.
You had Weaver guard it Yes, she was needed and you needed
the clicker, but I am not What I don't understand you should
keep going Zane Zane come on He's being a little dodgy with
us
Interesting Oh my gosh, it's like a...
It's like a target.
Something Zane's being a little sketchy about.
No, the batteries.
Oh.
Okay.
Why does this keep rolling all on its own?
Why does it keep... Why is it doing that?
Where is it got it?
Why is it getting all this?
This gives itself momentum to roll some more.
It's like, nah, nope.
Rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling.
Keep rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling.
Perpetual motion.
Yes.
Keep on... Whoa!
The ship!
What?
Wait, where are we?
Are we like... Oh, we're like floating in space or
something?
Not space.
The sky?
Something's going on.
It's pretty freaky.
Oh, boom!
I wouldn't say I'm gaming.
I'm on easy mode.
But yeah, I don't think there's anything wrong.
Some people like just want to experience a story.
They don't want to necessarily be a pro gamer about it
something.
And as long as there's harder options for people that do
want the challenge i don't see any issue with it you know
the bridge roads in the unnatural wind it was heralding the
enemy's arrival wait wouldn't leave this place alive uh is
this the gun yeah what's gonna happen here boom
Boom.
Oh, boom.
Oh, shoot!
That's what that means.
I thought like the ground might fall underneath them or
something.
Like the ground would crumble.
Not that they would get crumbled.
Oh,
it does!
Never mind.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, whoop, whoop.
Got a flare.
Whoa!
You're close to me.
I wish I could use the boom, but you guys came at me so
close.
I was like all the way already here when you guys started
coming after me.
Nice dodge, thank you.
I wonder what easy mode makes easier.
You know what I mean?
Like, is it...
Like, does it make dodge?
I can help you here.
Moments easier as well.
Oh, you can help me here?
Is Zane all powerful?
I like a challenge, but I generally like games for
experience me.
Like, I do a no death run.
But I want to experience the game as I do it.
There's a connection.
Yeah, I get it.
Just the number of enemies.
You fixed the foolish mistake I made with Barbara.
I like the way Alan Wake looks when he's going down, like on
the...
on the... when he's like, he's trying to be so careful.
He's like, ooh, gotta be careful.
Watch my step.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
He looks so goofy.
Rock!
Nothing beats good old rock.
Oh, don't fall.
They just don't fall.
It also appears they spawn even more from the tools word.
Oh, the enemies?
Or there's more tools?
Oh!
Nothing beats rock.
I threw that from all the way over there.
Holy cow.
Stop it.
Leave me...
Ouch.
That would be so embarrassing.
Leave me alone.
I'm trying to dodge.
Gosh.
Should I use this for those guys?
Flash?
What's happening?
Whoa.
Planning on playing through MGS for myself soon, but stealth
games are not my thing.
Good thing there's an easy mode.
Is there?
I can't remember.
There is for some of the games, though, for sure.
For some of the games, oh my gosh.
By birds!
I got my butt beat by the birds.
Can I get this guy?
Not from here.
Stinking birds.
Doodle-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Not
just birds!
Don't move!
Everything's fine.
Maybe.
I'm just thinking how glad I am on YouTube mode right now.
How in Stormtrooper M.
M, don't go.
Sorry.
I forgot I was playing a game.
I forgot I was the one...
I just reached the checkpoint and then I reached another
checkpoint i forgot i'm the one controlling him wake ran for
the light it was pointless he would never reach it his life
would be snuffed out just as easily as the very thing you
would save him you jerk with the light gone all i could do
was keep going i mean you got rid of the light but it's
still a lighthouse i just reached another checkpoint adys's
version of easy mode is pretty neat it has a toggle that
makes it so every time you die your character gets buffed up
to a certain Hoi!
I'm glad we hit the checkpoint.
My bad.
Careful?
Easy now?
Easy?
Alan.
Whoops.
Alan Butterfingers.
Alan Butterfeet.
Clumsy Alan.
That's what everybody calls him.
around the bush you have a lot of problems alan alan with a
lot of problems i'm so glad you decided to come back to me
oh wait okay oh since we're being so frank here alan and let
me just reiterate how happy i am that you've had this break
i would like to summarize your condition by all means and
please just let me know if you think i'm being unfair all
right i could just leave start with the obvious the car
crash untreated head trauma all due respect to Doc Nelson
but he's hardly a neurosurgeon I think that the injury has
affected you more than you realize yeah I have had bad
headaches then there's your history of substance abuse which
combined with your chronic insomnia has resulted in
hallucinations and extremely poor impulse control that's a
dangerous combination one which your wife has unfortunately
had to suffer from far more than you i know i know she
hasn't i don't think i'm exaggerating when i say that you
are existing in a state of all encompassing denial can i be
in the in the kitchen oh there i am and allows you to skirt
responsibility for your own actions oh i'm too in the door
your imaginary problems and dismiss
illusions your personal problems are assets that allow you
to save Alice perhaps even the world dr. Harmon I I think
that's spot-on I can't argue with any of that well I'm sure
I'm saying the obvious I don't want to labor the point but
well um no no I understand it's important that I face it
precisely Alan you've put so much effort and imagination
into this self-deception the point
I'm sick of hearing of your silliness.
This was just another attempt to confuse me.
By now I knew these phantoms and figments for what they
were.
Echoes of the pain, guilt and hopelessness, a part of me
wallowed in.
What I heard in there wasn't the truth.
It was just another toxic mirage.
It cut deep, but that made me all the more determined to
force myself to snap out of it.
I didn't want to be that guy anymore.
I had to make myself see the light.
They were like tools and stuff though.
One second.
Getting tired, sorry.
Oh no.
Oh, okay.
Oh, but my tools!
No!
Okay.
Alan Gambari!
Yeah, I made him tired.
He won't Alan wake again if he's too tired.
He's got Alan's sleep.
Paying my weekly veto tax, Quinn!
Thank you!
I hope you had a great day and enjoy the rest of the game.
Thank you so much!
Is there something I missed?
Oh, there's gotta be another one around.
Probably.
Down below.
Uh...
Go, go, go.
Oh.
Come on.
Come on, Alan.
Oh, there it is.
There's the tools.
Ouch!
Oh my god, don't get too close!
No, no, no!
Oh my god.
What a terrible...
What an actual terrible feature.
Like...
It's actually so messed up!
That they...
Allow...
Some game dev is laughing in sadistic glee.
Actually though...
Oh,
it's in here.
Is that the game?
Night Springs video game.
No, no, no, no.
Messed up.
Yeah, we're always going back to the woods now, aren't we?
Isn't that just so exciting?
Back in the woods.
Wait, where?
Oh, up there.
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d.
Is there anything else up here?
I feel like there should be, no?
Am I exploring for the sake of nothing?
Probably.
Ah!
Well done.
Thank you!
You have come far, but there's still a little further to go.
You must take full control of your own mind.
Reject all of the fantasies you have constructed.
that a lot of the stuff i've seen here is personal and ugly
as hell i'll admit it hurts but it's not fooling me i know
it's fake good you are aware the part of you bent on
self-destruction is not but you must be careful just because
you know the lies for what they are that doesn't make the
danger looking at this guy i'll make it i don't have any
choice here i cannot come any further
I guess.
What does Zane do while we're, like, during all of this, you
know?
What is that guy doing?
Wait, what is this?
Oh, that's the moon, I think.
Memory.
Hey, let me tell you something, Alan.
My wife.
I know how your mind works.
You screw up, then you start analyzing it.
I thought she called me a screw up.
You start writing all these horror stories in your head,
don't you?
Come on, I don't do that.
Yes, you do.
I know how it goes.
You're a complete failure.
I hate you and I'll never forgive you for whatever it was
that you did.
Am I wrong?
Oh, man.
I know you.
But Alan, it's all in your head.
It is.
I love you, and I'm not going anywhere.
Oh, my wife.
Ignite.
The trees?
Oh, the lighthouse again.
Whoa!
One shot!
I thought I saw something.
Oh, oh my god.
Alan, be careful.
Alan doesn't know.
Alan can't see.
Alan needs to up his prescription, I think.
They kept coming.
There were too many of them.
Hards and hordes of them swarming over the landscape.
Oh, it's a flashbang over there.
awake and this time they would get it with sheer numbers or
the or the lighthouse is a flashbang uh-oh clear
oh nice the
lighthouse is on my side clear
whoa clear the
lighthouse is on my side Oh my god.
Clear!
Oh my god.
Holy!
It's so awesome!
Clear!
Uh oh.
Wait, Lighthouse, I need you again.
Ouch!
Lighthouse, I need you!
Thank you.
From behind!
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
That was so stinking close.
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh.
I just kind of have to like fend for myself until we get the
flash.
No!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
But it doesn't get everything.
It doesn't get all of them, I think.
Oh my god, oh my god, please!
Oh my god.
Ouch!
There we go.
Oh gosh.
I just have to get them like out of from behind the rocks
and uh...
Yeah.
I can get this guy.
I'll take care of him.
Oh,
you jerk.
Trying to clear.
There we go.
Holy cow.
Holy...
Wait, what the hell did it just do that for?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I'm lost!
I'm like getting autopsy-turvy.
The camera angle is going crazy on me.
Oh my gosh, how much longer?
At least we got a checkpoint.
At least we got the checkpoint.
Oh my god, I can see more words in the...
In the... not...
In like the...
future oh
get them lighthouse get them yeah lighthouse get them you're
about to get guy it's not you guys though oh shoot yeah
you're about to get guy oh my gosh sometimes there's guys
and I don't even know that they're here you know There's
sometimes guys that I'm like, oh, you were right behind me.
This is awesome.
I love the lighthouse.
Here it comes.
Incoming.
So many guys.
Really is like a horde that they said.
Really is the horde that they said.
was.
Oh, we can just run from here, maybe.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Alan, run.
Ouch!
I was relieved to have made it here, but I wasn't sure what
was going to happen now.
Okay.
We made it to the lighthouse.
We made it.
Oh, I hear a video game.
I hear it.
It's going.
Where are you?
Oh, you guys hear it too?
Maybe it's upstairs.
The ghost house.
Why is it the ghost house?
I can't see it.
I wasn't sure what the dark presence had done to him if he
couldn't follow.
now on i was on my own no still he had got me this far i
would never have made it by myself this thing was going to
end it wouldn't be long now what is going on in the real
world though because like rose was all messed up and then
the fbi guy nightingale was all messed up so i just i'm
curious what's going on
while all this is happening Oh,
it's not on.
Oh.
Return?
Ouch!
How in...
I'm gonna...
I swear.
Wait for Alan Wake 2.
Dang!
It was a pretty wild deer fest.
I guess we'll find out in 2 then.
That's exciting.
Maybe.
Alan 2 is scary.
though no so what does that mean whoa i was surprised by the
change of scenery but not much i was starting to understand
the symbolism the way the dark place flow wow it's gorgeous
alan did something all right
bridge oh my eyes oh my god the most roundabout bridge ever
nothing can be easy in your stinking brain alan wake i swear
to god the island is right there very hey al feeling kind of
depressed here no what so zane's your new buddy now i feel
I'm sorry!
That doesn't mean I don't have any feelings.
Sorry, Barry.
Why did we do it like this?
Oh my goodness.
Thing is, you need to get all rational here.
Abandon your fantasies, right?
Well, I kind of hate to say this, pal, but I'm one.
Fine.
You're abandoned.
Bye.
What are you going to say to me?
Oh, nothing this time?
Okay.
Okay, bye.
At least Alan Wake doesn't have abandonment issues.
Maybe.
Oh my god.
What a saying is the only way you're getting in that cabin
is through me.
It's one of those killings.
your darling's things but hell you're used to that big shot
writer am i right it was in everything it was even taking
the people away to turning his friends against me they were
all against it my track track come what is that i had it
since august i was in a coma for all of august oh my god dr
thunder sleeper good luck with everything Oh my god!
What?
I hope you- I hope everything goes well for you!
Are we gonna go kill Barry?
What does it say about you?
When you're this desperate to keep yourself from- No!
Barry!
I'm earning the 15% commission!
I'm so disappointed in you!
It's great that you first make yourself an imaginary friend
and then you can't even get along with that guy people
skills al you're a master oh nice what's this i'll take
everything oh my god unlimited batteries and everything easy
mode rocks oh let's crack that writer's block of yours alice
oh you're a master of crime fiction and exploits
Uh...
Oh my god, my aim.
Survive the assault is what it says.
Okay.
What if I just had unlimited...
Oh no!
My friends!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch!
...
Impulse control of a...
Impulse control.
Ouch.
I'm doing that so that birds don't get me, you know?
Oh, and they still do.
That's crazy.
Oh!
Because they make money all the time.
Oh, I lost my unlimited everything!
Never mind.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oh no, it's right here.
Oh my god.
I can't aim.
My unlimited batteries.
Where'd he go?
Are you speaking to me, Barry?
Sorry, I'm not paying attention.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
Uh-oh.
Shadow Barry saying things.
I haven't been paying attention.
It's totally not.
Oh my god!
Barry, don't be so mean!
Don't be so mean, Barry!
You're gonna regret that.
You're gonna regret hurting my feelings.
You're gonna regret that!
Dang, Barry's tanky.
Oh!
Barry!
Billy running low on patience here!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh!
Stinking birds, man.
Oh, why am I not using a flare?
You're driving me nuts!
You're driving me nuts.
Oh.
Ouch!
Where'd he go?
A bear?
Oh!
Wait, there's a shotgun right here.
Switch.
Where'd he go?
Nice.
Goodbye, not Barry.
I don't feel bad at shooting him because he's not Barry.
You know?
I don't feel so bad about it.
How do I enter the cabin?
Oh, over here.
Time to shoot me.
Oh.
Not our Barry.
Yeah, he was real mean, exactly.
Oh, God, he's just on the ground.
What's this happening to me?
Oh, he's so pathetic.
Give him a hug.
Give him a hug, Alan.
What is this happening to me?
I'm you, but cooler.
Just like that.
My mind was clear.
Well, that's it.
I could think clearly again.
Oh.
But I couldn't survive in this place the way he had.
And I might not make it back a second time.
Leaving this place would be hard.
Maybe impossible.
Just write it, Bozo.
I got out.
I left the dark world and I...
Am fine.
It was too easy to get lost in the dark place.
If only that were that easy IRL, I know.
I was ready to curl up and die.
Let myself slip away.
Ready to curl up and die, this guy.
But here I was.
The yet unwritten future waiting to unfold before me.
Alan Wake 2.
Imagine, it just says that.
My name is Alan Wake.
And I'm a writer?
Yeah!
That's it!
That's the end of the DLC!
What?
What's going on?
I'm sorry, I fear...
These were not necessary.
Like, I could have predicted all of that was happening in
the darkness.
Why was I told to... Why was I told to play these?
Congrats on beating Alan Wake and you don't gotta wait 13
years for a sequel like I did.
the remedy verse yeah
rainbow road appeared i left the end yeah not wait it will
happen again in another town a town called your ran or or
drow read backwards No.
Unable to log into Epic Online Services, please connect your
connection and restart.
Thank you, Epic Games.
Elsie, I feel like I was so unnecessary.
I guess if you, like, you know, we were in the middle of
playing Alan Wake 1 and then Alan Wake 2 and waiting for
more, like, waiting for Alan Wake 2 to happen, and you're
like, I'm just itching for some more Alan Wake.
action you got 20 guide i feel like it
i think i asked i think i was like what happens to berry i
can't remember if people said you'll find out in the dlc or
you find out in american nightmare but uh just a heads up i
don't plan on playing american nightmare sorry if that
disappoints you but i will play control and then Alan Wake
too.
Because his name is Alan Wake, he's a writer!
Character development.
Alan learned to not suck.
I guess that's fair.
That is true.
If you won't play American Nightmare, at least listen to its
song, Balance Slays the Demon.
My previous message about another town is a hidden message
in it.
Oh, I see, I see.
is a rioter?
I know, crazy, right?
Crazy, right?
Spoilers!
I enjoyed, I will say though, this first episode of this
DLC, the first one, I mean, I struggled hardcore.
I was stressed out though.
I was stressed out of my mind.
But the second one, oh, I liked the different kinds of
levels.
Like the Ferris wheel, that was pretty cool.
Like the different, and like the booms and everything.
Like there was stuff in it that was pretty fun.
Also, Ballad Slays the Demon is just a good song.
Thanks, Thomas.
Thank you so much for the super chats.
Oh, American Nightmare briefly shows what happens to Barry,
but doesn't go into depth.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, but...
skim through the video so you can see some silly mp mv stuff
or american nightmare that's i could do that probably but um
i uh i think you know uh playing the first level was a true
testament of my skills they were like you do you know alan
wake Since you don't plan to play American Nightmare, it's
revealed in that game that after Alan disappeared, he went
on to be an agent for old gods of Asgard.
Oh, Barry did.
Okay.
Oh, that's so sad.
Does it say that he remembered everything, you know?
Like, he knows where Alan is.
Because I would hate for, you know.
That's so sad.
slash genuine?
You think so?
He's aware.
The DLC for the second game will...
Wait, the game is better.
Second game is better.
American Nightmare also gives you a little bit of insight on
Mr. A little bit of insight on Mr. Scratch as he's the
antagonist in that game.
That's the guy that... Yeah, that's the thing.
is like this game like Zane brings up Mr. Scratch and then
it's like no you don't know who that guy is oh
Mr. Scratch is a serial killer and torments Alice who is
still looking for Alan she's still looking for us I think
we've learned Alan is crazy and his words have power but he
can't get out of his own way but like three times over per
DLC good job Thank you!
Mr. Scratch is very important after this game.
Cool!
I'm excited then.
Excited, excited then.
Who are you cheering for in the Super Bowl?
Um...
I'm cheering for...
Uh, team...
Glorp, Glorp?
But, you know, I understand also that Zoop is also pretty
good.
So, uh...
I'm just...
I'm just here for the vibes.
That team kind of fell off?
No!
That's a hard take!
Who?
I actually...
I have no idea who's...
I don't know anything about the Super Bowl.
I did see, though, the...
The one commercial that was Jurassic Park.
The plot is essentially Alan trying to escape through an
episode of Night Springs that he wrote.
It's the American Nightmare.
Wait, that's so fun sounding, though.
The premise sounds fun.
But I've heard that the gameplay gets a little...
But yeah, I'm excited to go into control.
I might take a break before I do.
it um but i am really i mean i started this so i could play
alan wake 2 so i'm very excited for alan wake 2.
go see hawks oh the patriots the lulley lulley lulley the
vibes for control are great where can i can i get it on
steam i haven't even bought it yet i do have alan wake 2.
It was a...
Oh.
I see on Steam they have Control Ultimate Edition.
It has very positive reviews.
Is it good?
Okay, I'm going to add it to my wish list and see if it goes
on sale.
That's the one.
Okay, okay.
Cool.
Winner of over 80 awards, Control is a visually stunning
third-person action-adventure that will keep you on the edge
of your seat.
Now, in the least, sorry, in the least spoiler-ly way you
can explain, what does Control, how is Control and Alan Wake
connected?
Are they like the same universe or?
um also i love that it says this similar to games you've
played and it shows silent hill f and outer wilds okay same
universe okay okay okay cool i've heard that it's like not
it's one of those things where it's like not super important
that you have to play but then like before alan wake to but
if you do play it before alan wake to you you kind of just
like are like ah during certain things you know I feel like
I compare it to like playing Metal Gear in timeline order
versus release order.
So it connects in cool ways.
Okay, cool, cool.
The Wakeverse.
Same world, some items and events overlap.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
It gives a lot of context about what's happening.
Oh, I'm excited then.
I'm looking at like some of the screenshots from it.
We look like we play as like a badass bitch.
Hell yeah.
Oh, wait.
That thing's kind of ugly, creepy.
Uh-oh.
Exciting.
But yeah.
Wait.
I think I have a meeting tonight and I don't remember what
time.
Me and Densetsu girlies are meeting up.
Oh.
In an hour.
I think I'll go eat dinner then.
Thank you guys.
Will we, I guess we, with this we have officially finished
Alan Wake 1.
So control will happen next.
Exciting, exciting.
Have a nice meal.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Remedyverse.
Control is what made me fall for remedy games.
Really?
I'm excited then.
Oh, I'm excited.
What else do they have?
Developer.
Control Resonant.
Is that like Control 2?
break.
Alan Wake's American Nightmare.
Max Payne.
That's a multiplayer thing.
Basically, yes.
Control got me into Alan Wake.
No way!
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
This isn't even out.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, we're getting into this at the perfect time then.
Explore a warped.
Maybe I shouldn't read that.
I leave.
I do not see.
Nice.
Quite the break is kind of awful.
More TV show than game.
You have to understand.
I am Metal Gear fan.
I understand.
I understand movie over game.
yeah don't read that oh yeah i i close i close the window
she's kojima proof you have to understand i love cinematic
games though that's like so that's like that's like enticing
me more than being like nah you you wouldn't like it also i
just noticed villain thank you so much for the donald thank
you for all your wonderful streams not to overshare but
thank you for giving me something to wake up to our love for
you would feel not a lake but an ocean thank you thank you
villain quantum break is fun just not as good as controller
alan wake too it sounds like alan wake the first like what
we just played was kind of like the the the bottom of the
tier list rather like not that it's like bad but it's like
you know it only goes up from here so i'm very excited to
keep playing twin peaks watch along one day also did you see
that they're making a movie of exit eight inch convenience
store i did yes i did know about both
twin peaks
sam lake you hack affectionate we'll see if i ever get to do
max pain maybe one day maybe i gotta be like super remedy
pilled and I'll be like, I need more rippity games.
I need more.
Twin Peaks, though.
You have Twin Peaks?
Mama Mia.
But yeah, I have no idea how much Netflix series Quantum
Break is.
It's like exact 50-50 split.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
Of like cutscene versus game?
Doryko, thank you so much for the whole episode.
Thank you!
Epilogue Minto beat the self-absorbed and pretentious
writer's silly DLC.
TV Allen had tried to stress her out and make her quit, but
she was way too awesome to be stopped.
Minto got herself something nice and yummy as a reward and
had a happy and relaxing day.
Thank you!
Calling it Alan Wake the first makes it sound like he has
two little brothers in the same name.
He does.
I should open the game up because when I close out of it,
you don't hear it.
There's no like no PC ever anything.
You beat a chapter, then there's a full live action TV
episode to watch.
In Quantum Break.
Wait, that's insane.
I think Max Payne is a game you'd like just by itself.
Yeah?
You don't name siblings second or the third.
Alan Wake the third.
In the most non-spoilery way.
Do you think that there will be an Alan Wake 3?
If you've played Alan Wake 2?
I'm just curious.
Probably.
Definitely.
Yes, yes.
Yes, yes, probably.
With the...
They couldn't make Alan with Alan 3.
100% they confirmed it.
Wait, they did?
I don't know what Remedy is up to now.
Well, clearly they're still doing stuff because they have
the Control Resonant coming out.
It says Dev is Remedy and Publishing is Remedy.
So that's on Steam.
So clearly they're still kicking it.
and they're still they're still uh wanting to do stuff and
still working on stuff so alan wake 3.
hopefully it doesn't take 13 years to make like the in
between alan wake and alan wake 2 right because because um
hopefully oh that sorry that was my controller because
Let me put my controller away.
One second, also.
One second, one second.
I would like to stream it.
And if it's a long time from now, I would kind of suck.
I don't know how long I'll be streaming for.
Just stream for 13 years.
Yeah?
You'll still be around in 13 years?
You'll still be hanging out with me in 13 years?
Are you going anywhere in the next 10 years?
I have no idea.
What if someday I see the light?
13 years stream with the line.
Hey, if you still find me fun, I mean, it'd be fun to keep
streaming then for as long as I could.
Oh.
But I'm going to go eat dinner now.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you for having so much fun with
me.
Thanks for, thank you for pushing me through the first
episode.
And the encouragement and everything.
I appreciate it.
It was a tough one, but we powered through.
I didn't even need to reset to easy mode.
We just did it.
We did it, baby.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
We believed!
She's a gamer!
Fun stream today!
Thank you!
Um...
See you next time probably on Tuesday.
Uh, well I will be streaming!
I still don't know what I...
Guys, I don't know what I'm streaming this week.
I'm streaming Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday.
Because I have my jazz show on Friday.
So I won't be streaming Thursday.
Spank!
Thank you so much!
Uh...
Pretty good.
But, um, part of me wants to play, uh, oh my gosh, what's it
called?
Okay, I want to play Jurassic World Evolution 3.
Okay, here's my dilemma.
Jurassic World Evolution is basically like zoo tycoon, but
with dinosaurs.
But the reviews say...
The reviews say that...
good, but it's not great for the price because it's just
like the first and second one, you know?
But I never played the first and second one.
So I was like, maybe it's okay that I only get the third
one, but then also it's $60.
So I was like, I wish it were on sale.
Is that the one with Jeff Goldblum talking to you?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Hmm.
It's probably fine to only play three then.
Probably, right?
$60.
I'm like, dang.
I've been spoiled by indie games, I think.
Meantora, we'll watch you stream until I can't anymore.
Your streams are always a lot of fun.
I'm very comfy to watch.
Teyaki, thank you.
Yeah, people were saying that 60 is, like, a lot for it
because it's so similar to two.
In those games, you can do a ride POV.
place your missing park experience.
You know!
You know, somebody recreated Dinosaur the Ride in Minecraft.
There's a server.
There's like a...
There's a server you can go to and you can ride Dinosaur the
Ride.
And it has the in...
The ride audio and everything.
Dino Mudge.
Mudge.
Minecraft crazy people for the win.
True, true, true.
But yeah, I- I get how arrogant I too.
Blue!
What is spooky?
Oh, spooky, spooky donut.
Dinosaur Zoo Game buttons!
Go get those dinoes.
What the heck?
Thank you.
Obviously, I mean, you know, it's more so...
I could afford it.
place but it's more so like uh like uh how do i say you know
when i see reviews of people being like this game should
have been a dlc for the second game or things like that you
know i don't want to reward money hungry behavior you know
what i mean yeah it's the principle of the matter like i
want to be a responsible shopper and I want to you know I
want to be like I mean I appreciate it so much I don't want
to be like boo your dono but it's more of a glorified
expansion it's just yeah like I I want to be you know I want
to be someone who thinks that if something is really good
then I will you know especially that much money it's a good
mindset you think so
I don't base my opinion on reviews I try it myself or do my
own research on it I think reviews are research note a
little bit but definitely understand wanting to be careful
with your money I think reviews I mean obviously you're
going to get biased reviews sometimes but if you read a good
amount of them I think that you especially i think someone
saying that the a game is a a sixty dollar game is a being a
being a expansion of another game that was just as expensive
and could have just been a uh a dlc or something is like a
good valid criticism you know that's how i think that's
License games are always outrageously expensive.
You know what?
That's so true.
Reviews are useful for figuring out both expectations.
Right.
Don't get me wrong.
There are so many positive reviews.
It says mostly positive for the thing.
I don't think it, like, crashes or runs poorly.
But I'm also just like, dang, it's kind of stinky that
summer.
Some people are like, man, this...
I had to pay for the same game again, just with a few more
features.
I don't know.
I might just get it.
Because I want to play Dinosaur Tycoon.
And it has a Ketzalcoat Atlas.
I want him.
If it has him, I want that guy.
And he was in Jurassic World, so he should probably be in
the game.
Right little guy.
I have a Quetzalcoatl this figure on my desk.
He's so cute.
They should make a ride about that.
Agreed.
Call it up like he's a cat.
He's a baby.
He's my little baby.
He's sitting right on my desk next to Snake.
In fact, I have two snakes on my desk because I got two
more.
I gave one to Mogu and then I got two more to replace the
one that I lost I didn't lose him I gave him away but you
know I got two more to replace it's kind of like if you cut
off the head of a hydra then two more grow back it's the
same but my bag that I keep my little snakes in is full so I
can only
so I can only I can only I have to keep two of them on my
desk.
Deploying the snakes.
Yeah.
I'll take a picture and show you guys my Ketzel Kowatles and
my Snakes and my Hanamaru Obake.
They're all together.
It's like everything that I love in one little area.
Now you need another bag, truly.
I want to get an Eda bag that just is full of them.
Full of my little men.
The Snake Shrine.
Yes, yes, yes.
More.
Do you have any interest in playing Terraria?
It's not that I don't have an interest.
I have played it before.
But I think it's easier and more fun with friends.
I think it's one of those types of games.
Spread my code.
Speaking of dinosaurs, they found a fossil in China of one
that was apparently covered in porcupine-esque quills.
Maddie, what was it called?
What?
That sounds awesome.
I'm gonna look it up.
Oh?
My god.
I just realized...
Okay.
My phone.
Are you okay?
Right before stream, I was watching...
Oh my god.
No.
I was watching some TikToks.
I had my phone face down so I couldn't see it.
And I just picked it up.
And it's been playing the same TikTok, probably for the past
four hours.
Oh my god.
And it's like...
It's a TikTok of one of the...
Oh my god.
One of the Broadway shows of Wicked.
So now my timeline is probably going to be like, this girl
loves wicked.
Yeah, my algo is cooked!
No!
It's gonna be there like, don't give her anything else.
She only wants wicked.
No!
Oh my God, it's been playing this whole time.
She watched this video for four hours straight.
I sure hope that the person that posted this can't see it
like what if i'm the top watcher i probably am there's no
way any of any other person is watching this video more than
i have at this point
is this girl okay it's what i fall asleep to i just can't
help it oh my god no why why did i pick up my phone oh i was
looking for the dinosaurs Dinosaur, China, poor cute pine.
Whales.
Gotta nuke my alga with just minto.
It already is.
It's so funny.
Oh!
A dinosaur with spikes exhibiting unprecedented properties
discovered in China.
Eww.
This thing looks ugly.
The reconstruction of it.
What the hell?
It looks like...
Like a bird with sharp feathers, you know?
Neat.
Dino in shambles.
If you ever want to see the saddest downgrade of a dinosaur,
check out the Spinosaur.
That guy looked so cool.
And then over time they were like, I think he looks a little
bit more like he kept evolving.
Like the reconstruction of him.
Like kept, kept.
They're like, ah, maybe this isn't so accurate.
And they just kept.
Now he looks like a nerdy bird.
Didn't they try and make it a seal?
It really looks something very similar.
So it's very different.
funny.
It's fine.
We love all iterations of the Spinosaurus.
Google Autofill, Spinosaurus, Downgrade meme.
No!
They're embarrassed about Jurassic Park 3, so they've been
nerfing it ever since.
Jurassic Park!
I think my biggest qualm about Jurassic Park is
like dinosaurs that they make.
So that, like, there's just fake dinos.
And I feel like sometimes people are going to think they're
real.
I really don't like the...
I'm like, there's so many dinosaurs.
There are actually so many dinosaurs.
And you have to make...
You have to make one up.
It's so strange.
Velociraptors aren't real.
Dinosaurs couldn't turn invisible?
Wait, I actually...
I don't even know that one.
I haven't watched, like...
I've only watched the most recent Jurassic World.
I haven't watched, like, the first couple of them.
A lot of inaccuracies in the first one, too.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, Jurassic Park...
Yeah, I mean...
I think that's always probably gonna be the case, unless we
can learn cloning.
We'll never know what, uh...
Dinosaur truly looks like unless we are able to bring one to
life, you know?
They gave the dinos the stealth suit.
The first one has cuttlefish genes and can turn invisible.
Or time travel.
Right, right, right.
Minto telling us to clone dinosaurs.
Terrifying.
Terrifying thought.
This elevator's too heavy!
Cheetosaurus, Verizon Raptor.
What is this?
I think, though, it's fun when, like, when some dinosaurs
get more recognition because of Jurassic Park, though.
That's fine.
You know?
Yeah, did you guys see the new Netflix show?
I don't remember.
I think it's, like, dinosaur.
It might just be called Dinosaur, the new Netflix, like,
dinosaur documentary thingy thing.
Exciting.
I'll keep Netflix for another day, I guess.
I will keep Netflix for one more day.
The one narrated by Morgan Freeman.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ever thought of playing ARC?
From my understanding, ARC is also a game that's better
multiplayer?
Or at least I've only seen it multiplayer?
And also, I've heard it's very sweaty.
Yes.
I've also heard that it's very, very sweaty.
Like a, yeah, a time sink.
So...
Probably not, unfortunately.
Arc seems scary.
Genius park idea.
Oh, a park exhibit, designer dino who can be invisible and
not seen whatever it wants.
Come and see it, everyone, if it feels like it.
Maybe the dinosaurs watch along.
That might be fun.
That could be fun.
Aibool Arc server.
You guys are gonna just murder me.
You guys would just come...
Actually, do I... I think I own Arc.
I think I played it once.
Oh, I do!
I do!
165 gigabytes later.
I don't even think I have enough space on my computer to be
honest.
Wait.
I have...
Oh, I cleared up some games.
I have 200 gigs left.
I'll take up, I'll take up.
Yeah, time for a new drive.
For real.
Cool.
Well guys, I am gonna head out now though.
Thank you again for hanging out with me.
Alan Wake.
waking up with me.
It was a good time.
It wasn't all good time.
It's always a good time with you guys.
So, the game...
But, with you guys, it's always a good time.
So, enjoy your dinner.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
We just stayed on the Alan Wake screen.
I forgot to move over to my bedroom or the cafe.
Oh, my god.
Wait, can I leak something?
I, after the last Densetsu collab, you know, we kind of, we,
we host them, host the collabs, like on our, on our own
computers.
And I was, after the last one, like, so we have, like, our
own loading music and everything when we, when we do that.
And I was like, can we get, like, a Densetsu BGM, like, of,
Like, Densetsu MVPs or something.
I was like, can we get, like, a Bossa Nova version or
something?
And, oh my gosh.
It's so cute.
I want to use it for, like, my BGM when I'm talking in the
future and stuff.
I'm going to leak a little bit of it.
I'm going to.
Nobody said I can't.
It's so cute.
Makes me want a jazz version.
Or, like, a, you know, like a chill version of the song now.
It's so good, no!
Yeah!
It's so...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I want to...
Hold on.
The chorus is so good.
This is just a draft, too, so.
And it, like, loops, so...
Ah, it's so good!
It's so good!
Yeah, so you can expect to hear that in the future.
Yippee!
like can we get like a bossa nova version of dented to mvps
so that we can like you know have that for when we are
chatting or for collabs and things like that so yeah they've
they got on that immediately after i ask so i'm so happy
minke leaks okay i'm gonna leave now before anybody catches
me
Thank you everybody, thank you, thank you, thank you, I will
see you when I see you next Bye-bye